WILL CALL THE COMMITTEE TO OF
HIGHER ED. TO ORDER AND WITHOUT
A PRESENT --
QUORUM PRESIDENT WE WILL BEGIN.
AS A SUBCOMMITTEE.
AND WE WILL BEGIN WITH ITEM
NUMBER ONE SENATOR LEYVA
.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU MEMBER.
GOOD AFTERNOON I WOULD FIRST
LIKE TO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR HARD WORK ON THIS
IMPORTANT BILL MUCH APPRECIATED.
S. B. THREE TWENTY WOULD REQUIRE
ALL ON CAMPUS STUDENT HEALTH
CENTERS THAT PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES
TO PROVIDE MEDICATION FOR EARLY
PREGNANCY TERMINATION FOR THEIR
STUDENTS BY JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO ACCORDING TO
THE GUTTMACHER INSTITUTE SINCE
TWO THOUSAND OVER ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION WOMEN IN THE UNITED
STATES HAVE TERMINATED EARLY
PREGNANCIES.
THROUGH THE USE OF MEDICATION
ABORTION.
IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN WOMEN
AGE TWENTY TO TWENTY FOUR
ACCOUNTED 434% OF ABORTIONS THE
LARGEST FOR ANY AGE GROUP.
STEP PROCESS WHERE PATIENT TAKES
TWO SETS OF PILLS OVER THE
COURSE OF TWO DAYS DURING THE
FIRST TEN WEEKS OF PREGNANCY.
ACCORDING TO UC SAN FRANCISCO
STUDY ABORTION MEDICATION HAS
SERIOUS ADVERSE AFFECTS ONLY AND
POINT. ZERO ZERO POINT 5% OF
CASES WHICH IS LESS THAN TYLENOL
AND*.
THAT SAME STUDY ALSO FOUND THAT
EVERY MONTH OF TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY NINE STUDENTS AT THE
THIRTY FOUR UC AND CSU CAMPUSES
SEEK MEDICATION ABORTIONS AT OFF
SITE HEALTHCARE FACILITIES.
MANY CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES ALREADY OFFER
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
SERVICES SUCH AS PREGNANCY
OPTIONS.
COUNSELING AND CONTRACEPTIVES
AND ALL CONSIDER THESE SERVICES
TO BE A COMPONENT A BASIC
HEALTHCARE SERVICES.
MEDICATION ABORTION IS A SAFE
PROCEDURE AND IS CLINICALLY
SIMPLER THAN MUCH OF THE ALREADY
OFFERED CARE ACT COLLEGE STUDENT
HEALTH CENTERS SUCH AS DIABETES
MANAGEMENT.
MENTAL HEALTH CARE AND DIAGNOSED
ME DIAGNOSIS AND TREATMENT OF
SEXUALLY TRANSMITTED DISEASES
CURRENTLY 51% OF STUDENTS ACROSS
THE U. CNC ISSUE SYSTEMS ARE LOW
INCOME AND TWO THIRDS OF YOU SEE
STUDENTS AND ONE THIRD.
OF CSU STUDENTS DO NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO RELIABLE
TRANSPORTATION.
IF A STUDENT HOUSE TO GO TO AN
OFF CAMPUS PROVIDER THAT DOES
NOT ACCEPT THERE'S THEIR STUDENT
OR OTHER PRIVATE HEALTH
INSURANCE.
PAYING FOR MEDICATION ABORTION
MAY BE A SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL
BURDEN.
IN TOTAL TWENTY TWO UC AND CSU
CAMPUSES ARE MORE THAN THIRTY
MINUTES AWAY FROM THE CLOSEST
ABORTIONPROVIDER.
VIA PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION THESE
BARRIERS ARE WORSENED SINCE ONLY
15% OF THE CLOSEST OFF CAMPUS
ABORTION PROVIDERS ARE OPEN ON
WEEKENDS MEAN THAT STUDENTS HAVE
TO ALTER OR MISS CLASSES EXAMS
OR WORK. TO ACCESS THIS
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT BEING ABLE
TO ACCESS MEDICATION ABORTION ON
COLLEGE CAMPUSES.
CRITICAL SINCE WOMEN MUST
RECEIVE THIS CARE WITHIN THE
FIRST TEN WEEKS OF PREGNANCY.
AT MOST WOMEN DON'T EVEN FIND
OUT THEY'RE PREGNANT UNTIL THE
FIVE TO SIX WEEKS ALONG.
DENYING COMPREHENSIVE AND
ACCESSIBLE REPRODUCTIVE CARE ON
CAMPUS INTERFERES WITH THE WELL
BEING AND ACADEMIC SUCCESS UP
WOMEN AND DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTS STUDENTS OF COLOR AND
LOW INCOME STUDENTS.
WITH ME TODAY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT IS ALICE CARTWRIGHT A
PROJECT DIRECTOR FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF OBGYN A REAP
REPRODUCTIVE SCIENCES AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SAN
FRANCISCO.
AND JESSICA A STUDENT AT UC
RIVERSIDE.
SENATOR LEYVA BEFORE THEY
PROCEED YEAH I'VE --
OMITTED JUST READ IN A STATEMENT
DATA.
THERE ARE GUIDELINES FOR THIS
COMMITTEE --
FOR BILLS TO BE HEARD THAT IS
ALWAYS TESTIMONY FROM TWO
WITNESSES FOR SUPPORT.
AND TWO WITNESSES FOR OPPOSITION
TWO MINUTES EACH.
THANK YOU SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE TODAY.
MY NAME IS ALICE CARD RIGHT AND
I'M A PROJECT DIRECTOR AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SAN
FRANCISCO WHERE PART OF A
RESEARCH PROGRAM CALLED
ADVANCING NEW STANDARDS IN
PRODUCT OF HEALTH OR ANSWER.
AT UCSF WE RECENTLY CONDUCTED TO
RESEARCH STUDIES RELATED TO
CAMPUS ACCESS TO MEDICATION
ABORTION CALIFORNIA WHICH ARE
BOTH RECENTLY BEEN PUBLISHED IN
PEER REVIEW JOURNALS.
THE FIRST STUDY BUT BY MY
COLLEAGUE DR DANIEL GROSSMAN
COLLECTED INFORMATION FROM ALL
OF THE UC AND CSU STUDENT HEALTH
CENTERS TO UNDERSTAND IF THEY
HAVE THE CAPACITY TO PROVIDE
MEDICATION ABORTION ON CAMPUS.
YOU'VE BEEN GIVEN A COPY OF THE
REPORT SO YOU KNOW THE
CONCLUSION FROM THIS RESEARCH
THAT IT WOULD BE VERY FEASIBLE
TO OFFER MEDICATION ABORTION AT
THE UC AND CSU STUDENT HEALTH
CENTERS.
THE METHOD MAY BE SAFELY
PROVIDED BY OBGYN ENDS FAMILY
MEDICINE OR INTERNAL MEDICINE
PHYSICIANS ADVANCED PRACTICE
CLINICIANS SUCH AS NURSE
PRACTITIONERS CERTIFIED NURSE
MIDWIVES OR PHYSICIAN
ASSISTANTS.
OR ANY PHYSICIAN A CLINICIAN
WHO'S BEEN TRAINED TO PROVIDE
IT.
THE NATIONAL ACADEMIES OF
SCIENCE ENGINEERING IN MEDICINE
ISSUED A REPORT EARLIER THIS
YEAR ON THE SAFETY OF ABORTION
GENERALLY AND MEDICATION
ABORTION IN PARTICULAR.
THE REPORT ALSO HIGHLIGHTED THAT
ADVANCED PRACTICE CLINICIANS MAY
PROVIDE THE SERVICE AND IT CAN
BE PROVIDED IN A VARIETY OF
HEALTH CARE SETTINGS. FOR THE
SECOND STUDY WHICH IS CONDUCTED
BY OUR TEAM AT UCSF LED BY DR I
SMOKE POT THE AYE.
WE SOUGHT TO UNDERSTAND THE
DEMAND FOR MEDICATION ABORTION
FROM AMONG STUDENTS THAT YOU SEE
IS AND CS USE AND THE CURRENT
BARRIERS THEY FACE ACCESSING
CARE.
WE IS A MULTI STEP METHODOLOGY
TO GENERATOR FINDINGS AND I'M
HAPPY JUST TO DISCUSS THAT
METHODOLOGY IN MORE DETAIL IF
THERE'S ANY QUESTION.
IN THIS STUDY WE FOUND BETWEEN
THREE HUNDRED AND TWENTY TWO AND
FIVE HUNDRED IN NINETEEN UC AND
CSU STUDENTS SEEK MEDICAION
ABORTION OFF CAMPUS EACH MONTH.
THIS AMOUNTS 220-092-30030 SEVEN
CSU STUDENTS AND A HUNDRED AND
THIRTEEN TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO
YOU SEE STUDENTS PER MONTH.
THE MEDIAN TIME AT STUDENTS HAVE
TO TRAVEL TO THE NEAREST HEALTH
FACILITY THAT PROVIDES ABORTION
BY PUBLIC TRANSIT WAS THIRTY
FOUR MINUTES EACH WAY.
AND TWENTY TWO CAMPUSES FOR MORE
THAN THIRTY MINUTES AWAY FROM
THE NEAREST PROVIDER BY PUBLIC
TRANSIT.
GIVEN THE TWO VISITS ARE
GENERALLY RECOMMENDED FOR
MEDICATION ABORTION CARE MANY
STUDENTS WHO HAVE TO TRAVEL OVER
TWO HOURS.
WE ALSO FOUND THAT THE AVERAGE
WAIT TIME UNTIL THE FIRST
AVAILABLE APPOINTMENT THE
FACILITIES CLOSE TO CAMPUS WAS
SEVEN DAYS.
MANY UC AND CSU STUDENTS HAVE
LIMITED FINANCIAL RESOURCES TO
SUPPORT GOING OFF CAMPUS FOR
CARE.
OVER HALF FOR LOW INCOME 42% OF
YOU SEE STUDENTS AND 21% OF CSU
STUDENTS EXPERIENCED FOOD
INSECURITY AND ABOUT 10% OF CSU
SUCH STUDENTS SUFFER HOUSING IN
SECURITY INCLUDING HOMELESSNESS.
IN ADDITION MANY STUDENTS TWO
THIRDS OF YOU SEE STUDENTS AND
ONE THIRD OF CSU STUDENTS DO NOT
HAVE ACCESS TO A CAR.
THE TIME COMMITMENTS REQUIRED
FOR TRAVEL TO AN EXTERNAL
FACILITY ARE COMPOUNDED BY THE
APPOINTMENT AVAILABILITY AN
INHERENT DELAYS IN SCHEDULING AN
APPOINTMENT OFF CAMPUS.
SINCE ONLY 15% OF THE CLOSEST
FACILITIES ARE OPEN ON WEEKENDS
STUDENTS MAY BE FORCED TO MISS
CLASSES WORK OR OTHER SCHOOL
COMMITMENTS DURING THE WEEK
WHICH MAY DETRIMENTALLY IMPACT
THEIR SCHOOL SUCCESS.
ON TOP OF THE FINANCIAL AND TIME
COSTS STUDENTS HAVE TO NAVIGATE
AN EXTERNAL HEALTHCARE SYSTEM
SEPARATE FROM THE STUDENT HEALTH
CENTER THEIR HEALTH CARE HOME.
WHERE THEY WOULD LIKELY SEEK
OTHER PRIMARY HEALTH CARE?
AND AS WAS MENTIONED DELAYS IN
OBTAINING CARE COULD PUSH
STUDENTS PAST TEN WEEKS OF
PREGNANCY THE CURRENT LIMIT FOR
MEDICATION ABORTION.
ACCESS TO ABORTION CARE FOR
THOSE WHO WANT IT CAN BE
IMPORTANT FOR COLLEGE
PARTICIPATION AND SUCCESS AND
UNIVERSITIES CAN FULFILL THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY TO STUDENTS BY
PROVIDING DESIRED HEALTH CARE
AND SUPPORT FOR THE REPRODUCTIVE
LIFE DECISIONS.
STUDENTS SEEKING ABORTION NEED
CONVENIENT ACCESS TO HEALTH
CARE.
SERVICES THAT DO NOT INVOLVE
UNNECESSARY INTERRUPTION AND
SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS TO THEIR
COMPLEX LIVES.
THE NECESSITY OF LEAVING CAMPUS
FOR THE SERVICE WHEN OTHER
HEALTH CARE SERVICES CAN BE
OBTAINED ON CAMPUS.
UNNECESSARILY BURDENS THOSE
STUDENTS WHO NEED AN ABORTION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE OF MY NAME IS JUST
ZERO SALAS AND I AM A RECENT
GRADUATE OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA RIVERSIDE.%
ASIDE FROM BEING A STUDENT I WAS
ALSO UNIVERSITY EMPLOYEES AND
THE PRESIDENT OF PLANNED
PARENTHOOD GENERATION ACTION FOR
TWO YEARS.
TODAY I CONTINUE TO ADVOCATE FOR
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE AND THIS IS
MY ABORTION STORY.
I WAS JUST BEGINNING MY THIRD
YEAR AT UC RIVERSIDE WHEN I HAD
MY ABORTION.
IS AROUND OCTOBER WHEN I STARTED
TO FEEL SICK SO I DECIDED TO GO
TO THE STUDENT HEALTH CENTER.
I THOUGHT IT WAS JUST THE
STOMACH FLU BUT THE DOCTOR TOLD
ME THAT I WAS PREGNANT.
I DIDN'T KNOW WHAT TO DO.
BUT I DID KNOW THAT I STILL HAD
TWO YEARS LEFT OF SCHOOL AND I
WAS NOT FINANCIALLY STABLE.
I NEEDED AN ABORTION.
THE DOCTOR THEN SET UP AN
APPOINTMENT WITH A DIFFERENT
DOCTOR FROM YOU SEE OUR AND THEN
FROM THERE THEY REFERRED ME TO
THREE DIFFERENT FACILITIES THE
FIRST FACILITY.
DID NOT EVEN OFFER ABORTIONS THE
SECOND FACILITY WAS ABLE TO
SCHEDULE ME AN APPOINTMENT BUT
NOT UNTIL MID NOVEMBER.
IF THAT WEREN'T ENOUGH TWO WEEKS
BEFORE MY APPOINTMENT THE SECOND
FACILITY DENIED MY INSURANCE
CLAIMING THAT I DID NOT HAVE THE
UC STUDENT HEALTH INSURANCE
PLAN.
I FELT EXTREMELY DISCOURAGED
THIS ENTIRE ORDEAL SENT ME ON A
DOWNWARD SPIRAL.
THIS WAS THE FIRST TIME I WAS
TAKING MY UPPER DIVISION
COURSES.
BUT I STOPPED CARRYING.
MY GRAY SLIP DRAMATICALLY AND I
WAS PLACED ON ACADEMIC
PROBATION.
I WAS A FIRST GENERATION
STUDENT.
AND I THOUGHT I HAD RUINED EVERY
OPPORTUNITY THAT I EVER HAD.
NOT KNOWING WHAT TO DO.
A COLLEGE STUDENT HEALTH CENTER
AGAIN.
I'M ASKED ABOUT MY OTHER
OPTIONS.
IT WAS THEN THAT THEY CLARIFIED
THAT IT WAS NOT LIMITED TO THE
REFERENCES THAT I WAS GIVEN.
SO FINALLY I SCHEDULED AN
APPOINTMENT WITH PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AND GOT MY PROCEDURE
DONE IN DECEMBER.
MY STORY IS NOT UNIQUE.
THANK YOU.
IN MY SITUATION COULD HAVE BEEN
AVOIDED AT THE STUDENT HEALTH
CENTER HAD PROVIDED MEDICATION
ABORTION FOR THE STUDENTS ON
CAMPUS.
S. B. THREE TWENTY WOULD ENSURE
THAT PEOPLE LIKE MYSELF.
COULD OF GOTTEN THE CARROT THAT
I NEEDED WHEN I NEEDED IT.
MY GRADES AND HEALTH SUFFERED
BECAUSE OF IT.
THE STUDENT HEALTH CENTER SHOULD
HAVE A HOLISTIC REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE.
I HOPE YOU ALL WILL SUPPORT
SENATE BILL THREE TWENTY SO
STUDENTS LIKE ME.
HAVE ACCESS TO ALL OF OUR
OPTIONS THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
OF OTHER WITNESSES [inaudible]
SUPPORT.
AND IT AS AS WE BEGAN WITNESSES
AND SUPPORT.
YOUR LIMITED TO YOUR NAME WHAT
GROUP YOU'RE WITH.
AND YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL.
OTHER THAN THAT I'M [inaudible]
A JOB.
I'M FIGURE FROM WHAT'S IN THE UC
BERKELEY SOON WITH THE WOMEN'S
FOUNDATION OF CALIFORNIANS JUNE
TWO NIGHT IF REPRODUCTIVE
JUSTICE AT BERKELEY AND I URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MIRANDA FIELD ELLIOTT FORMER
STUDENT BODY SENATOR UC BERKELEY
I URGE YOU TO VOTE YES.
MY NAME IS COURTNEY AMHERST
UNITE UC DAVIS NAY URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS A DEEP ECONOMIST TO
NOT UC BERKELEY AND I URGE YOU
TO VOTE YES.
MY NAME IS TIFFANY CHIANA WITH
STUDENTS PER YEAR.
LIKE I'M WITH CAL SURGEON I URGE
YOU SQUARE YES ON THE SP.
THREE HI MY NAME IS WILLIAM XU
AND I'M --
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT OUT OF
SCHOOL ON OUT OF STATE STUDENT
ENERGY THIS POINT YES.
MY NAME IS DIANE TOBER I'M AN
ASSISTANT PROFESSOR AT
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SAN
FRANCISCO AND A RESEARCHER AND
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH I URGE YOU
TO PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME WAS BRITTEN HERE IT I'M
A RECENT YOU STILL A CROWDED
PART OF CALIFORNIA THAT UNITES
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE AND I URGE
YOU TO VOTE YES.
MANY OF THEM MILLION MICKEY AND
I'M A STUDENT OUT CSU
BAKERSFIELD AND I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ASIA AND I'M ALSO A
STUDENT AT UC BAKERSFIELD AND I
URGE TO SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS MITCHELL FOSTER
IMERYS AND MASTERS GRADUATE FROM
CSU CHICO AND URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS LEVEES BECAUSE THEN
YOU KNOW THAT I'M A STUDENT AT
UC DAVIS I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ALLEGE NICK MUST SAY
I'M A CS AND ANA COLLEGE AND I
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ANDY PARTY AND I'M
STUDENT AT CYPRESS COLLEGE AND I
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JUST SINGLE MAN I'M A
STUDENT OF FOURTEEN COLLEGE AND
I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MERELY CYNICAL ITIS
I'M A STUDENT AT SAN JOSE STATE
UNIVERSITY AND AIRED YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS COUNTED YOU KNOW I'M
FROM THAT IS A STATE UNIVERSITY
HAD AND I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
ESTO.
MY NAME IS DANA OF A MEMBER OF
THE WOMEN'S POLICY INTO TO A CO
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL AND I
GRADUATE FROM UC DAVIS ENERGY
SPORTS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI I'M SARAH HUTCHINSON WITH ARC
FOR WOMEN AND GIRLS A CO SPONSOR
FOR THE SPELLING WE URGE YOU TO
VOTE YES THANK YOU.
RACHEL CHO WITH ACCESS WOMEN'S
HEALTH JUSTICE CO SPONSOR OF
THIS BILL.
AND A UC BERKELEY CLASS OF
TWENTY TWELVE AND I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS CAN I AYE PAJAMAS
STUDENT AT CV AND I URGE YOU TO
VOTE YES ON THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS GINNY MCDONAGH
RECENT GRADUATE FROM CAL STATE
LONG BEACH AND I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MELISSA SOME HILL
LARA FROM CYPRESS COLLEGE I URGE
YOU SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS CALVIN SENDS A
STUDENT AT UC BERKELEY AND IDEA
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS SMITH ACROSS YELLOW I
WOULD JUST CARE IN THE FEMINIST
MAJORITY AND I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THE SPELL.
MY NAME IS MOLLY SOULS ARE I'M A
STUDENT AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND I URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS RUSTY THE KEY
COULD SUICIDE A STUDENT AT UC
BERKELEY ENERGY TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
HI MY NAME'S CARL EVEN NARROW I
GRADUATED FROM UC BERKELEY LAST
YEAR HERE WITH THE WOMEN'S
FOUNDATION OF CALIFORNIA ASKING
YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HI I'M A MOGWAI OF SUDAN A BE
SEE BERKELEY AND URGES TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS NATALIE ERICKSON
I'M A STUDENT ATHLETE IN COLLEGE
AND I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
HI MY NAME IS THESE NOTING ANNA
AND THE SANTA CRUZ SUIT AND URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS CARL EDWARDS I
AM A RECENT GRADUATE OF UCLA AND
I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS DEAN ON YOGA
MCGREGOR FROM UC BERKELEY I URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HI I AM AS PATRICIA TAURUS I AM
A STUDENT UC BERKELEY AND I URGE
YOU TO VOTE YES.
HI MY NAME IS NATALIE CHL I AM A
STUDENT AT UC SANTA CRUZ AND I
URGE YOU TO VOTE YES.
HI AM HARRIET STEEL I'M A
STUDENT AT UC BERKELEY AND I
URGE YOU TO VOTE YES ON S. B..
THREE TWENTY HI I'M TRUST THE
PHILIP BMX DIDN'T US NUMBER
STATE UNIVERSITY AND I URGE YOU
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS GABRIELLE MILANO I'M
A STUDENT AT SAN JOSE STATE
UNIVERSITY ENERGY TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
HELLO LYNNE WHEN CELL BOARD
MEMBER OF NEVADA COUNTY CITIZENS
FOR CHOICE AND BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONAL WOMEN OF NEVADA
COUNTY PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
LAYING SIERRA ON THE PUBLIC
POLICY DIRECTOR CITIZENS REJOICE
NEVADA COUNTY --
AND A MEMBER OF BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONAL WOMEN AND I KNEW WE
ARE IN.
WILL SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS SIMON MONDAY WITH
THE WOMEN'S FOUNDATION OF
CALIFORNIA ENERGY TO SUPPORT THE
FELL.
HOW MANY HAS BEEN A MINOR WORK
WITH ALAMEDA COUNTY STOLEN AND I
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL?
HI MY NAME IS FONG AND FROM
THOUGH WOMEN'S FOUNDATION I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MONICA SHRIVER MEANT
STUDENT AT UC BERKELEY AND I
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
AND LEAVE US GAVE IT A STUDENT
UC BERKELEY AND ENERGY TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SYLVIUS
A LEASH ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
AND STRONG SUPPORT.
LARA LOW FROM STUDENTS
REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM EASY DAVIS
I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
I'M AN IMAGE I'M AWARE SHOW I'M
ALSO FOR INSTANCE REPRODUCTIVE
FREEDOM AT UC DAVIS AND I URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS CAITLYN DONOVAN I'M A
STUDENT AT UC DAVIS MAYOR TO TO
SUPPORT THE SPELL.
MY NAME IS CAMERA LANA AND I'M
FOR A STUDENT UC DAVIS AND I
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THE SPELL.
MY INCOME ACLU OF CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MEYER DRAMMA CALIFORNIA LATINOS
FOR REPLY JUSTICE IN SUPPORT AND
A CO SPONSOR OF THE BILL.
HI MY NAME IS JACKIE CAST JANOS
AND I'M A FIRST YEAR MEDICAL
STUDENT AT UCSF ENERGIES TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
SARAH RAMSEY YOU ON BEHALF THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ALICE KESSLER IN BEHALF OF THE
QUALITY CALIFORNIANS STRONG
SUPPORT.
MEGAN BARGRAVE FORMER COLLEGE
STUDENT CALIFORNIA ON BEHALF OF
THE WILL STONE PROGRESSIVE
DEMOCRATS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THE NASA TELLIS LOS RIOS
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENT ON
BEHALF OF CAMPUS ACTION FOR
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE AND
INDIVISIBLE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
SARAH BARBANEL FORMER GRADUATE
STUDENT UC BERKELEY IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
ELIZABETH WELLS FROM PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES A
CALIFORNIA AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
BUT TIME AND I UNIVERSITY
SERVICES GO STUDENT AND I OR DO
SUPPORT THE SPELL.
I'M A TIME WHEN GOV FROM
UNIVERSITY OF SAN FRANCISCO
ENERGIES OF SUPPORT THE SPELL.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHOWN SMITH
CROWLEY REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF
UNIVERSITY WOMEN FOR CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS JENNY CROSS YELLOW
ENERGY TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
AND I WILL I JUST REPEAT WHAT I
SAID BEFORE.
OF THE POLICY OF THE COMMITTEE
IS TESTIMONY FROM TWO WITNESSES.
AFTER SUPPORT TO WITNESSES AND
OPPOSITION. TWO MINUTES EACH.
MY NAME IS MARY LEE SHRIDER I'M
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF RIGHT TO
LIFE OF KERN COUNTY AND WE
APPRECIATE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK.
SINCE THE INTRODUCTION OF S. B.
THREE TWENTY THOSE WHO PROMOTE
THE BILL SAY IT'S ALL ABOUT
ACCESS THAT HOURS OF TRAVEL TO
THE NEAREST ABORTION CLINIC THE
COST OF ABORTION PILLS AND OTHER
IMPEDIMENTS. TO OFTEN STAND IN
THE WAY OF OUR DAUGHTERS
EDUCATIONS THE TRUTH HOWEVER IS
THAT THERE IS NO DEMONSTRABLE
LACK OF ACCESS ESPECIALLY IN
CALIFORNIA.
WERE ACCORDING TO THE LATEST
NUMBERS FROM THE GUTTMACHER
INSTITUTE THERE ARE FIVE HUNDRED
AND TWELVE ABORTION PROVIDING
FACILITIES AND NONE OF THE
ABORTION STRICT RESTRICTIONS
THAT ARE OFTEN FOUND IN OTHER
STATES.
CITED IN THIS MEASURE IS THE
DRIVING ME BEHIND IT IS THAT IN
ORDER TO REACH ABORTION CLINICS
STUDENT SPACE PROHIBITIVELY
EXPENSIVE TRAVEL TO CLINICS.
THAT MAYBE HOURS FROM THEIR
CAMPUS CITY COUNTY OR EVEN
GEOGRAPHIC REGIONS THIS IS A
GREAT EXAGGERATION IS GEOGRAPHIC
ANALYSIS SHOWS.
THAT ALL UC AND CSU CAMPUSES ARE
LOCATED AN AVERAGE OF ONLY SIX
MILES FROM THE NEAREST ABORTION
PILL PROVIDER.
AS TO THE COST OF THE ABORTION
PILLS YES THEY ARE EXPENSIVE BUT
THEY'RE ALSO COVERED.
STUDENTS WHO DON'T HAVE HEALTH
INSURANCE ARE UNEMPLOYED OR
SIMPLY DON'T WANT THE ABORTION
TO SHOW UP ON THEIR PARENTS
INSURANCE.
CAN QUICKLY QUALIFY FOR MEDI CAL
PRESUMPTIVE ELIGIBILITY A STATE
PROGRAM THAT ENSURES THE STUDENT
BEARS LITTLE TO NO COST FOR HER
ABORTION.
IT'S BEEN SAID THAT ARE YOU
FORTY SIX IS SAFER THAN TYLENOL
AND BY AGRA THOUGH NEITHER OF
THESE HAS BEEN KNOWN TO PRODUCE
HEAVY BLEEDING NAUSEA AND STRONG
THE DOMINO PAIN.
IN WOMEN AS THEY EXPELLED THEIR
PRE BORN BABIES.
SINCE APPROVING THE ABORTION
DRUG MIFEPRISTONE IN TWO
THOUSAND THE U. S. FOOD AND DRUG
ADMINISTRATION AND A TWENTY
SEVENTEEN SUMMARY REPORTED FOUR
THOUSAND CASES OF SERIOUS
ADVERSE EVENTS ASSOCIATED WITH
THE USE OF THE DRUG.
INCLUDING ONE THOUSAND WOMEN WHO
REQUIRED HOSPITALIZATIONS FOR
SEVERE BLOOD LOSS INFECTIONS AND
TWENTY TWO WOMEN WHO DIED AFTER
TAKING THE DRUG.
ALSO A CONCERN IS THE FACT THAT
THE BILL CONTAINS NO
CONSCIENTIOUS OBJECTOR EXEMPTION
FOR EMPLOYEES WHO ARE MORALLY
OPPOSED DISTRIBUTING ABORTION
PILLS.
AT THE JUNE TWELFTH ASSEMBLY
HEALTH COMMITTEE HEARING ON THE
BILL WHEN SENATOR LABOR WAS
ASKED ABOUT THE LACK OF SUCH AN
EXEMPTION SHE DISMISSED THE
CONCERN WITH.
AND I QUOTE FOLKS DON'T HAVE TO
WORK THERE IF THEY DON'T WANT TO
AS IF OUR UNIVERSITIES WERE
PRIVATELY OWNED BUSINESSES AND
NOT PUBLIC STATE ENTITIES
THEY'RE OBLIGED TO AT LEAST
CONSIDER.
THE RIGHTS OF ALL OF OUR
CITIZENS.
CLEARLY THERE IS NO COMPELLING
REASON TO DUPLICATE READILY
AVAILABLE MEDICAL SERVICES AND
BRING ABORTIONS ONTO OUR COLLEGE
CAMPUSES WE URGE YOU TO PLEASE
VOTE NO ON THIS EGREGIOUS AND
UNNECESSARY BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS KAMALA
RODRIGUEZ AND I WORK WITH
STUDENTS FOR LIFE OF AMERICA I'M
HERE TODAY REPRESENTING NINETY
SEVEN GROUP STUDENT GROUPS FROM
ACROSS CALIFORNIA ARE OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL.
SINCE JANUARY FOUR THOUSAND FOUR
HUNDRED AND FORTY THREE PETITION
SIGNATURES HAVE BEEN COLLECTED
THROUGH THE STUDENTS ON THEIR
CAMPUS.
I AND THEY'VE BEEN AND IN THE
COMMUNITY --
WHILE ON CAMPUS AND IN THE
COMMUNITY WE FOUND THAT DESPITE
PERSONAL IDEOLOGIES AND STUDENTS
AND ADMINISTRATORS ALIKE THE THE
VERY LARGE ISSUES THAT WOULD
ARISE AT THE PASSING OF S. B..
THREE TWENTY STUDENTS FROM
FRESNO STATE CSU LONG BEACH AND
CSU FULLERTON SAT DOWN WITH
THEIR CORRESPONDING PRESIDENT TO
DISCUSS CONCERNS ON THE BILL.
AND WHILE EACH MEETING WITH
DIFFERENT FORM EVERY. FOR
LEGISLATION THEY HAVE EXTREME
CONCERNS WITH THE AND THAT NOT
ONE PRESIDENT FROM THE CSU
SYSTEM ACTUALLY WANT THIS BILL
TO PASS.
WHEN ASKED WHY THE PRESIDENT'S
WEREN'T SPEAKING UP IF THEY WERE
SO OPPOSED TO THE BILL ONE
PRESIDENT RESPONDED SAYING THE
ULTIMATELY HAD NO SAY IN THE
MATTER?
THIS GOES FAR BEYOND THE MISSION
OF HEALTH CENTERS AND THE
LIABILITY SHALL BE PLACED UPON
THE CAMPUS HEALTH CENTERS IS
MONUMENTAL.
THE PRESCRIBER AGREEMENT FORM OF
MYTH NEVER PRACTICE DATES THAT
THE PURPOSE SCRIBE THE PROVIDER
MUST MEET CERTAIN QUALIFICATIONS
INCLUDING THE ABILITY TO PROVIDE
SURGICAL INTERVENTION IN CASES
OF INCOMPLETE ABORTION.
AND THAT THE FDA REPORTED THAT
3% OF WOMEN DO NEED SURGICAL
INTERVENTION --
OVER FIVE HUNDRED WOMEN SEEKING
THIS A MONTH WAS MENTIONED AND
THAT'S FIFTEEN STUDENTS A MONTH
WILL NEED EMERGENCY CARE A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY STUDENTS PER
YEAR.
WHEN ASKED IF ITS POSITION ON
THE BILL THE LEAD PHYSICIAN AT
CAL POLY POMONA STATED WE WOULD
BE INITIATING A TREATMENT THAT
WE IN ALL LIKELIHOOD WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO FOLLOW THROUGH WITH?
STUDENTS WOULD NOT HAVE TO GO TO
THE STUDENTS WOULD HAVE TO GO TO
THE EMERGENCY ROOM AND MIGHT NOT
GET THE CARE THEY WANT IN THE
EMERGENCY AND IT MIGHT COST THEM
TEN TIMES MORE THAN WHAT THEY
HAVE PLANS TO BEGIN WITH.
CAMPUS IS DO NOT HAVE THE
EMERGENCY FACILITIES AVAILABLE
IF A STUDENT HAS AN ADVERSE
REACTION TO TAKING THE
SUPPRESSED ALL IN A TWENTY FOUR
HOUR HOTLINE IS NOT GOING TO
ALLEVIATE THAT.
MY COLLEAGUE REPORTED IT V. --
SIDE EFFECTS OF THIS BILL ONE
THAT STUDENT HOLLY PERSON
BECAUSE OF THE HOT AND REPORTING
THESE SYMPTOMS AND SHE WAS TOLD
THEY WERE NORMAL AND TO SEEK
EMERGENCY CARE IF THEY GOT
WORSE.
SHE DIED IN A HOSPITAL SHORTLY
AFTER.
IT'S YOUR JOB TO PROTECT THE
STUDENTS.
COST TO IMPLEMENT AND SUSTAIN
THIS BILL ARE ASTRONOMICAL AND
WHILE WE APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS
TO CREATE A PRIVATE FIND IT IS
UNCLEAR WHERE THE FUNDING WILL
COME FROM AFTER THE INITIAL
FUNDS ARE USED.
SO HOW ARE UNIVERSITY IS GOING
TO BE ABLE TO MAINTAIN THESE
FACILITIES AND THE TRAINING FOR
THE PROVIDER IS IN FIVE TEN OR
FIFTEEN YEARS.
THERE IS ABSOLUTELY NO
PROHIBITION OF STUDENT FEES ARE
TAX DOLLARS.
BLUE USE ONCE THE INITIAL FINEST
BANKS AND IT STUDENTS HAVE
EXPRESSED THAT THE HIT TUITION
COSTS ARE HIGH ENOUGH SO
[inaudible]
FILM.
THANK YOU WITNESSES IT OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
COME FORWARD AND AGAIN --
IF YOU GIVE YOUR NAME THE GROUP
YOU'RE WITH AND YOUR POSITION ON
THE BILL.
OTHER IN THAT WILL CUT YOU OFF.
I AM SOO EARNER FROM BIGGER
STILL PART OF RIGHT TO LIFE KERN
COUNTY IN ANOTHER THROUGH ADULT
CHILDREN AND I ASK YOU TO OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS KIMBERLY ARCHIE'S
I'M A FULL TIME STUDENT ATHLETE
AT THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY BAKERSFIELD AND
PRESIDENT OF THE NEWMAN CATHOLIC
CLUB AND I ASK YOU TO PLEASE
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I'M SISTER ELAINE.
ELAINE BENEDICT THEY HELD BACK
AND I I URGE YOU. TO OPPOSE THIS
BILL THE UC ALL THE CATHOLIC
SOME REPRESENTING.
AND IT'S MY FIRST TIME UP HERE
SO.
CATHOLIC SOME REPRESENT.
SO DO IT RIGHT OKAY.
MY NAME IS REVENUE ANGELO FRASER
FROM BAKERSFIELD CALIFORNIA
BOARD MEMBER OF RIGHT TO LIFE I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME'S ONE AT SALES I'M
SERVICE THE DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR LIFE AND ON
BEHALF OF OUR ELEVEN THOUSAND
MEMBERS WE ARE JOB NO VOTE ON
THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS ELIZABETH COR
AND I WAS STUDENTS FOR LIFE
CALIFORNIA ALL BE ATTENDING A
PEW IN THE FALL AND I ASK YOU TO
PLEASE VOTE NOW.
HELLO.
MY NAME IS RICKY SOBRE OF PER
ROOM THROUGH THROUGH LIFE IT
SOUNDS IS UNIVERSITY.
AND A HALF OF THE MANY CONCERNS
STUDENTS AND STAFF OF SIGNED OUR
PETITION BOTH PRO LIFE AND PRO
CHOICE.
WE HUMBLY AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOU TO PLEASE VOTE NO ON THIS
BILL IN JESUS NAME.
MY NAME IS VERONICA SAM STUDENTS
FOR LIFE ACASO UNIVERSITY CHICO
AND I URGE YOU TO OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
FRANCESCO ATTORNEYS YOU
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
FULLERTON.
AND I AM IN OPPOSITION.
HELLO I'M MY NAME IS ALEXANDRA
KUTCHI.
I AM A RESIDENT OF SANTA ROSA
OPPRESSION AT SAINT EUGENE'S
CATHEDRAL AND A MEMBER OF PRO
LIFE SAN FRANCISCO AND I URGE
YOU TO VOTE NO ON THIS OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS ON TO NINA ROSE
I'M A STUDENT AT UCLA AND A
MEMBER OF STUDENTS FOR LIFE
HIRED YOU TO VOTE NO ON THIS
BILL THINK YOU
HI AM MY NAME IS SARAH CORPS AND
THE NURSING STUDENT AND HIS USE
OF PACIFIC UNIVERSITY AND I ASK
THAT YOU VOTE NOW THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS BURKE PAUSE I'M A
STUDENT AT CAL STATE FULLERTON
I'M ALSO A CORRESPONDENT FOR
CRISIS PREGNANCY HOTLINES Y.
DEAL WITH THIS ON A DAILY BASIS
AND I ASK YOU TO VOTE NO ON SB.
THREE TWENTY HOW MY NAME IS ANNA
SINGLE I'M A STUDENT AND
EMPLOYEE OF UC SAN DIEGO
AFFILIATED WITH STUDENTS FOR
LIFE.
AND AS A LATINA STUDENT I ASK
YOU TO VOTE NO.
HI I'M RALPH MORE LEVY A MEMBER
OF SAINT ROSE CATHOLIC PARISH IN
SOUTH SACRAMENTO.
AND I STRONGLY URGE A NO VOTE ON
THIS AND AND LIFE BILL.
HI MY NAME IS ROBERT BYRD AND
MANY JUNIOR COLLEGE STUDENT IN
SAN FRANCISCO AND A VOLUNTEER
WITH THAT BOTH PRO LIFE
SENTENCES CHO AND NONSECTARIAN
MULTI PARTISANORGANIZATION IN
THE BAY AREA.
AND I URGE YOU TO VOTE NO ON SB.
THREE TWENTY MY NAME IS ROSEMARY
MOLINA EDUCATOR IN VALLEJO
CALIFORNIA ANDI URGE YOU TO
VOTE NO ON SB.
THREE TWENTY HI MY NAME IS MARY
WILD OR FIVE REPRESENT A STOCK
AS A STAFF MEMBER OF CSU CHICO
AND I URGE YOU TO VOTE NOW.
THANK YOU.
MICHELLE JORDAN BUSINESS WOMAN
CPA AND FORMER CAL STATE
FULLERTON --
STUDENT I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
SEEN ARMAND ARE IS I AM
CURRENTLY A STUDENT AT LONG
BEACH CITY COLLEGE AND I URGE
YOU TO VOTE NO ON THIS BILL.
HI ELISE ARMAND R. IS A RECENT
GRADUATE OF UC IRVINE ENERGY TO
VOTE NO ON THIS BILL.
HI CHERYL FICKLE I'M A CONCERNED
MOTHER AND GRANDMOTHER AND I
URGE YOU TO VOTE NO ON THIS
BILL.
MY NAME'S ANDREW RACHMAN I'M A
STUDENT AT PALOMAR COLLEGE IN
SAN DIEGO.
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME SHAH WHO SAYS IN
MOSTAR.
BOND CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
LONG BEACH A MEMBER OF THE
STUDENTS WELL I CHAPTER.
CALLOUSLY LA MISSION I COULD
SHOOT YOU BOTH NO I'M S. B. TWO
TRAINEE.
MY NAME IS ANNA AARON I'M THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA REGIONAL
COORDINATOR FOR STUDENTS FOR
LIFE OF AMERICA REPRESENTING
FORTY THREE STUDENT GROUPS
THROUGHOUT THE THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
IT REGION AND I URGE YOU TO VOTE
NO ON SB.
THREE TWENTY MY NAME IS DANIEL
AND I AM A STUDENT IN NAPA
CALIFORNIA AND A MEMBER OF THE
PRO LIFE --
STUDENTS FOR LIFE CLUB AND I
URGE YOU TO OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME'S SELENA LOPEZ I'M
A RECENT GRADUATE PRESENCE THEY
AND I'M WITH STUDENTS FROM
AMERICA.
HI MY NAME IS BERNIE THAT TCM A
GRADUATE STUDENT AT FRESNO STATE
IN THE PRESIDENT OF FRESNO STATE
STUDENTS FOR LIFE AND I URGE YOU
TO VOTE NO ON THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME'S HIS HIS HEAD UP IN
THIER CALIFORNIA AND I'M.
ON THE STEP OF FAITH AND I URGE
YOU TO VOTE NO ON THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ARI HONORABLY TEMAS
DO NOT UC BERKELEY AND I URGE
YOU TO VOTE NO ON THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ALEX YOU BERMAN
REACHED RECENT GRADUATE OF UC
BERKELEY AND I URGE YOU TO
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS LEE CITY GIOVANNA
NURSING GRADUATE FROM CAL STATE
LA A MAJOR NUTRITIONAL SCIENCE
WITH A OF FOCUS ON ETERNAL
NUTRITION OF MATERNAL CHILD
NUTRITION I OR YOU TO VOTE NO.
ON THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS SARAH CRESCENT
I AM A STUDENT AMERICA'S TO
COLLEGE AND I ASK YOU TO PLEASE
HIM NO ON THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS MARIA MOLINA I AM
A STUDENT AT FRESNO STATE A
MEMBER OF STUDENTS FOR LIFE.
AND I URGE YOU TO VOTE NO ON
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MARIA AARON AND ONE
COLLEGE STUDENT A MEMBER OF
STUDENTS FOR LIFE OF AMERICA
URGE YOU TO OPPOSE THE SPELL.
MY NAME IS MARY SERI CONCERNED
MOTHER AND GRANDMOTHER I URGE
YOU VOTE NO PLEASE.
HELLO MY NAME IS ISABEL PONCE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC
CONFERENCE AND I URGE YOU TO
VOTE NO ON THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS MARIA JOSE
FERNANDEZ FLOOD IS I'M A RECENT
GRAD FROM WILLIAM JUST
UNIVERSITY AND I AM THE SOCIAL
JUSTICE COMMITTEE CHAIR FOR HER
THE NEWMAN CATHOLIC CENTER IN
SACRAMENTO AND I URGE YOU TO
VOTE NO ON THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS LINDA MIM I'M A
REGISTERED NURSE SCRATCH IF YOU
SEE SANTA CRUZ UC SAN FRANCISCO
MOTHER IF YOU SEE STUDENTS I
URGE YOU TO VOTE NO ON THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS CECILIA XIMENES Y.
YOU [inaudible]
PRIDE THOUGH.
THE OLD THE PRO LIFE PEOPLE.
BUT NO IN THIS BILL PLACE.
MY NAME'S GREG BURKE CALIFORNIA
FAMILY COUNCIL PLEASER O. KNOWN
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI STEVE PATTON WITH THE
CATHOLIC DIOCESE OF SACRAMENTO.
SACRAMENTO URGING YOU'RE EITHER
A NO VOTE OR TO ABSTAIN THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON TREES SUMMER SUN
A FROM THE CENTRAL COAST OF
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING OUR
CALIFORNIANS FOR LIFE.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COME BEFORE YOU PERSONALLY. TO
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ALAN ROMBERG I'M A
MEMBER OF PRENATAL MURDER
OPPONENTS AND THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA.
ALUMNUS URGE YOU TO KEEP
PRENATAL MURDER OFF CAMPUS IS
NOT APPROPRIATE ON THE
EMPRESS'S.
YOUR NAME THE GROUP YOU'RE FROM
AND YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
THEY WILL BE JUDGED.
IT'S FUNNY SORT OF THIS WAS
SACRAMENTO AND PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC CONFERENCE
AND THAT.
AS A AS A BODY WE WE OPPOSE THIS
BILL WE ASK YOU. TO OPPOSE IT AS
WELL.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SCENE NINE ANY ONE IN A TWEENER
POSITION ON THIS BILL.
SEEING NONE I'M ASKS --
OPPOSITION.
TO PLEASE GO BACK AND I'M GONNA
CALL AT UC AND CSU TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS.
A OF THE MEMBERS [inaudible]
SO.
I BELIEVE WE HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES.
OF UC AND CSU NOT NOT NOT THE
STUDENTS NOT.
AND I WANT TO GIVE A UC AND CSU.
OPPORTUNITY.
SHARE ANY INFORMATION THEY MAY
HAVE.
AND ALSO TO ALLOW --
BUT MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TO
ASK ANY QUESTIONS OF THE OF THE
TWO SYSTEMS.
A GOOD AFTERNOON AND CHEERING
MEMBERS MY NAME IS ANGELA KELLY
ART AND I REPRESENT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA HEALTH
SYSTEMS.
AND ARE THE UNIVERSITY DOES NOT
HAVE A POSITION.
OF ON THIS BILL --
AS FAR AS A POLICY ISSUE YOU SEE
SUPPORT REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH. FOR
IT STUDENTS INCLUDING ABORTION
AND WE DO THIS NUMBER THREE
NUMBER OF WAYS ARE STUDENT
HEALTH INSURANCE PLAN IS SELF
FUNDED.
AND PROVIDE FOR A FULL ARRAY OF
HEALTH BENEFITS INCLUDING
COVERAGE FOR ABORTION SERVICES.
I'M OUR I'M WE HAVE WE HAVE A OF
LONG RELATIONSHIP I THINK WITH
SENATOR LEAVES OFFICE IN TRYING
TO WORK THROUGH SOME OF THE
TECHNICAL ISSUES OF THE SPELL.
THE POTENTIAL IMPLEMENTATION WE
STILL HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT
COST NEUTRALITY --
AT WHAT I REALIZE THIS IS A
POLICY COMMITTEE BUT WE DO HAVE
SOME FISCAL CONCERNS --
AND HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU.
AFTER MARTINEZ CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY.
US USE YOU HAS A PENDING
POSITION ON SENATE BILL.
THREE TWENTY WE UNDERSTAND THE
CONCERNS THE AUTHOR AND SPONSORS
TEACHER ACCESS --
TO ALL FAMILY PLANNING SERVICES
INCLUDE MEDICATION ABORTION.
HOW WE HAVE BEEN WORKING THE
AUTHOR AND THE SPONSOR MIXTURE
THERE ARE CONCERNS ABOUT
[inaudible]
IMPLEMENTATION.
HAVE BEEN NOT SHARING AND THRUST
OUT
WOULD LIKE TO SEE IF IT THE WAY
TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR GOING%
FORWARD TO ADDRESS THOSE
CONCERNS FRANKLY ARE WEAK.
WE UNDERSTAND BILLION ESTIMATES
OUR GOAL HERE TO ACTIVISTS THERE
ARE SOME ISSUES AS ALLUDED TO BY
MY COLLEAGUE COMMUTERS TO
CALIFORNIA.
HOW TO ANSWER THE QUESTIONS
GOING FORWARD ABOUT THOSE
CONCERNS ARE WITH ME TODAY A?
IN CASE THERE ARE STRICTLY
ISSUES A IS CHOI STEWART JAMES
WRITTEN SEGMENT STATE.
HEALTH CENTER ABOUT ALL RECALL
CENTERS ARE SELF OPERATED SELF
FUNDED -- AT
ALL LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT THAT SO
[inaudible]
IF YOU'RE CALL THE HEALTH CENTER
SEGMENT STATE YOU WOULD SEE A
BRAND NEW STAY THE ARK FACILITY
THAT'S NOT THE CASE AT ALL OF
OUR CAMPUSES AND SO.
SHE CAN ANSWER SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS AND SHOULD GIVE YOU A
SENSE OF HOW THEY ALL OPERATE
BECAUSE THEY ALSO ARE SOME
SUPPORT THERE ARE OR WHO THEY
ARE SUBTLE DIFFERENCES BETWEEN
ALL THE DIFFERENT CAPSULES.
AND WITH THAT I'LL OPEN IT UP TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
YEP MISS BAKER.
THANK YOU AM I APPRECIATE CSU
AND YOU SEE BEING HERE I AM I
WOULD LIKE TO HEAR MORE
SPECIFICS --
ABOUT WHAT.
WE SAID WE HAVE FISCAL CONCERNS
CAN YOU PLEASE BE MORE SPECIFIC
I KNOW WE'RE NOT.
BUDGET COMMITTEE BUT WE DO HAVE
TO DEAL WITH THE BUDGETARY
IMPORTANT IMPLICATIONS YOU HAVE
BOTH WITH THE TWO TERMS I HEARD
FROM BOTH OF YOU.
THERE ARE FISCAL CONCERNS AND
IMPLEMENTATION CONCERNS CAN YOU
GET MUCH MORE DETAILED SO WE
HAVE A FULL UNDERSTANDING OF
WHAT THEY MAY BE AND MISS BAKER
I'M GONNA ASK THE US SECRETARY
TO CALL A QUORUM BEFORE.
WE HEAR THE ANSWER.
MEDINA PRESENT BAKER.
ARAMBULA BLOOM CHVEZ
[inaudible]
IRWIN [inaudible]
KILEY LEVINE [inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
PATTERSON [inaudible]
QUIRK SILVA [inaudible]
SANTIAGO WEBER.
QUORUM IS PRESENT.
HE'D LIKE TO RESTORE YEAH I
THINK IT IT'S TIME AND I
APPRECIATE WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY.
FOR THIS TYPE OF LEGISLATION TO
THAT YOU'RE HERE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS AYE I WAS THEM.
UNDERSTAND A LITTLE BIT VAGUE
BUT I THINK WE COULD BENEFIT
FROM SPECIFIC SPECIFICALLY WHAT
ARE THE FISCAL IT FINANCIAL
ISSUES ARE CHALLENGES THAT YOU
SEE.
AND AS MUCH DETAIL AS YOU CAN
PROVIDE ON THE IMPLEMENTATION
CHALLENGES TO WE HAVE OUR EYES
WIDE OPEN ABOUT WHAT YOU'RE
POTENTIALLY DEALING WITH.
SO FROM THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA PERSPECTIVE ALL OF
OUR CENTERS ARE A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT WE ARE --
THAT ALL OF THE YOU SEE HEALTH
CENTERS ARE --
PRIMARY CARE HOMES FOR FOR
STUDENTS --
THE BILL CURRENTLY PROVIDES FOR
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND PER CENTER
AND TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND TO THE
SYSTEM WE DON'T THINK THAT'S
ADEQUATE GIVEN.
OF THE KIND OF BAD CHANGES WE
MIGHT MAKE NEED TO MAKE IN TERMS
OF SECURITY AND SOME OTHER.
THING SUB SO AND THE STUDENT
HEALTH CENTERS ARE FUNDED
THROUGH GENERAL FUND.
THROUGH PHILANTHROPY AND THROUGH
STUDENT FEES AND SO I'M ANYTHING
THAT'S NOT COVERED --
BY -- GRANT
DOLLARS WOULD BE A GENERAL FUND
OR STUDENT FEE COST --
AND THE BILL IS --
PROVIDES AFTER --
TWENTY TWENTY TWO IT'S IT'S
SILENT WHICH MEANS THOSE ONGOING
COSTS WOULD BE UNIVERSITY AS
STUDENT FEE COST AND STUDENT AND
OR GENERAL FUND COST AND OUR
STUDENT BODY IS VERY SENSITIVE
TO INCREASING IN FEES.
AND THIS BODY IS VERY SENSITIVE
TO HAVING ANY GENERAL FUND
BECAUSE ADDED TO OUR BASE --
BUDGET.
SO -- AYE I
THINK I'M A TOP OF THE LINE
THAT'S PROBABLY --
ARE CONCERNED THE BILL HAS GONE
THROUGH SEVERAL ITERATIONS SO
DEPENDING UPON ITERATION OUR
CONCERNS HAVE BEEN DIFFERENT IF
THIS HAS BEEN THE MOST RECENT --
THAT VERSION OF THE BILL IN
THESE ARE.
AYE CONCERNS NOW AS ITS FIRST
IMPLEMENTATION WE'VE HEARD IT.
ARE REPORTED THAT --
ABORTION --
BY MEDICATION SERVICES ARE
AVAILABLE THIRTY MINUTES AWAY
THAT'S NOT NECESSARILY TRUE FOR
ALL THE UC'S IT MAY BE TRUE
AGGREGATE IF YOU LOOK AT EVERY
SYSTEM IN.
DIVIDED BY SOME NUMBER BUT WE
HAVE SOME ABORTION SERVICES
WITHIN EVEN WALKING DISTANCE WAS
SOME CAMPUSES SOME CAMPUSES IT
IS THAT I'M TEN TO FIFTEEN
MINUTES.
HIGH RIGHTS SOME IT MAY EVEN BE
A FIFTEEN MINUTE DRIVE SO IT'S
IT'S NOT THAT --
I'M WE DO THINK THAT THAT THAT
THE COMMUNITY ACCESS IS THERE
THERE ARE SOME THINGS I THINK WE
COULD PROBABLY DO TO IMPROVE ON
THAT -- AND
SO -- I
THINK -- IN
TERMS OF IMPLEMENTATION WE JUST
WANTED TO MAKE SURE --
FIRST THAT THE COSTS ARE ARE
ARE.
PROBABLY ARE ARE ARE TOPPLING
CONCERNED ALONG [inaudible]
PURITY AND I MEAN I I DO THINK
THAT IT'S GOING TO BE --
SUPPORTING THE PROGRAM ONGOING
THE FUNDING --
TO SORT OUT THE PROGRAM WAS
GOING TO BE GREAT TO BUY
EQUIPMENT INTO THE TRAINING THAT
WE APPRECIATE OF ABOUT.
I WOULD I IMAGINE THAT OVER TIME
THAT STAFF WILL LEAVE --
AND GO TO OTHER OPPORTUNITIES.
BECAUSE FRANKLY WILD CAESAR'S
GREAT PLACE TO WORK THERE
PROBABLY ARE BUT OPTIONS FOR
EMPLOYEES FORCING PEOPLE OF
MEDICAL DEGREES. TO GO ELSEWHERE
AND RETAINING AND RECRUITING
STAFF -- IN
RETRAINING THE STAFF WILL BE AN
IMPORTANT PART OF ONGOING COST
--
AND THEN THE LIABILITY THAT
KEEPS ITS MAY BE INCURRING IT
YOU KNOW THE BREAST ARE MINIMAL
--
SO I DON'T WANT TO OVERSTATE IT
BUT BUT THERE IS GOING TO BE A
RISK AND IT'S GOING TO BE A
LIABILITY RISK ASSOCIATED WITH
THAT.
AND THE WAY WE A COST WORKS ON
LIABILITY AT CSU AS A CAPSULE
PAY A CERTAIN AMOUNT OUT OF
THEIR POCKET FIFTY TWO FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS EXPENSIVE
CAMPUS IN THEIR THEIR INSURANCE
PACKAGE THEY HAVE.
BEEN THE CSU PAUL SOUP CHICKEN
AFTERWARDS.
PICKING UP THE NEXT FIVE
MILLIONS LAST THE SYSTEM WIDE
POLICY WHICH COULD CONNECTS BY
MILLION DOLLARS AFTER THAT'LL GO
TO THE SYSTEM WIDE INSURANCE
WILL THEN TAP AND SO --
AGAIN LOW RISK WE DON'T KNOW WE
HAVE NO EXPERIENCE WITH THIS BUT
ABORTION BUT COULDN'T TELL YOU
THAT TO BE.
ONE ZERO I I REALLY CAN TELL YOU
BUT THAT THAT IS A CONCERN AYE
PIPER.
WATER THAT HIGHLIGHT
[inaudible]
DRESSED.
AND MAY I RESPOND AS WELL WERE
OF SURE I AYE I WOULD LOVE TO
HAVE MAY I HAVE A COUPLE
QUESTIONS FOR OUR GOOD AUTHOR
BUT YEAH YOU DON'T MIND WHILE
WERE ON THIS. TO THE AREA THINK
ACT MISTER CHAIR.
LINK SERDES GO AHEAD CENTER SO
THAT THIS IS WONDERFUL TO HEAR
FROM YOU SEE IS THAT THAT THE
COST IS A PROBLEM WE HAVE NOT
HEARD THAT BEFORE SO WE WOULD
LOVE TO KNOW WHAT THE NUMBER IS.
WE HAVE WORKED WITH OUR FUNDERS
TO MAKE SURE ALL COSTS WERE
COVERED SO IF YOU CAN GIVE US
THE NUMBER THAT YOU THINK YOU
NEED WE WOULD MUCH APPRECIATE
THAT.
A NUMBER TO THE TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND WILL GO TOWARD SET UP
COSTS.
WOULD TAKE THREE YEARS THEY WILL
HAVE THREE YEARS TO IMPLEMENT
THE TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND EACH
INSTITUTION YOU HEARD FOLKS TALK
ABOUT THE TWENTY FOUR HOUR
HOTLINE THAT TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS COULD GO.
TO A TO TRAIN PEOPLE TO ANSWER
THE PHONES BUT AS FAR AS ON
GOING AFTER THREE YEARS STATE
LAW PROTECTS INDIVIDUAL EXCUSE
ME PRIVATE INSURANCE INCLUDING
HEALTH INSURANCE AND MEDICARE
ALL.
ALREADY REIMBURSED FOR ABORTION
BERKELEY SHIP REIMBURSES A 100%
WITH NO QUE CO PAY OR DEDUCTIBLE
MEDI CAL HAS AN EASY ONLINE
APPLICATION PROCESS THAT COVERS
THE MEDICATION AT SIXTY SEVEN
DOLLARS.
AND THE PROCEDURE FIVE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY SO THAT SO I'M JUST
TRYING TO LET YOU KNOW THAT THE
COSTS WILL BE COVERED HALF OF C.
ISSUE CLINICS ALREADY ARE MEDI
CAL PROVIDERS.
THANK YOU CENTER A THINK YOU AND
AND JUST IN FOLLOWING UP.
THE I THINK US US ARMS IF YOU
NOT IN THE HEAD BACK AND FORTH
LIKE THERE WAS MAYBE SOMETHING
I'D LIKE TO KNOW WAS WAS.
THAT INFORMATION NOT THE CASE
ABOUT MEDI CAL COVERAGE OR WHEN
WE ARE SAYING MEDICAL COVERAGE
TALK ABOUT FAMILY PACKED HOWEVER
CABS ARE FAMILY PACK.
PROVIDERS --
WHICH IS SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT THAN
MEDI CAL --
SO THAT THAT THAT WAS THE
QUICKEST NOTHING.
OKAY THANK YOU AND FOR IF THERE
IS FOLLOW UP NOW UNDER EXISTING
SERVICES FOR A STUDENT WHO GOES.
TO A FACILITY IN TEN FIFTEEN
MINUTES AWAY --
IT WOULD SAY THERE IS A FOLLOW
UP NEEDS SOMETHING DOESN'T GO
RIGHT.
DO THEY GO CAMPAIGN AND DO THEY
GO NOW GENERALLY TO THE HEALTH
CENTER OR DO THEY GO BACK.
TO SAY IT'S A PLANNED PARENTHOOD
WHERE THEY GO TO SO IS THAT AN
ADDITIONAL AYE I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE STUDENT GETS
[inaudible]
CARE.
WHERE DOES THAT HAPPEN NOW AND
HOW WITH THE BILL AND YOU
UNDERSTAND THE DIFFERENCE YOUR
OBLIGATIONS UNDER THAT CONDITION
WILL CURRENTLY THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA DOES HAVE A TWENTY
FOUR HOUR HOTLINE ADVICE HOTLINE
FOR ANY STUDENT EXPERIENCING
EMERGENCY?
IF A STUDENT HAS I RECEIVED DAM
--
IT IF THIS MEDICATION OR ANY
OTHER MEDICATION AND HAVE THE
SIDE EFFECT THEY WOULD MOST
MATCH WE CALL THE PROVIDER THAT
PROVE THAT GAVE THE MEDICATION.
I'M ON WITH WITH THIS MEDICATION
MANY TIMES THE ARE CRITICAL
GYNECOLOGIST THAT GAVE THE
MEDICATION DOES HAVE TWENTY FOUR
HOURS EVER SO THEY WOULD KNOW.
THAT PATIENTS PARTICULAR CASE
BUT BUT GENERALLY IF THAT WERE
NOT AND IF THAT IF THAT WERE NOT
AVAILABLE THE EMERGENCY.
AND THROUGH JUST DO REGULAR --
LOCAL EMERGENCY ROOM WOULD BE --
THE RECOURSE THAT THE STUDENT
CENTER WOULD NOT BE --
THE RECOURSE --
HAVE FOR THAT I I ALSO JUST
WANTED JUST --
TO MENTION THAT IN TERMS OF OF
BILLING THE UNIVERSITY IS NOT
SET UP THE STUDENT NOW SENDS DO
NOT BILL.
AND THEY DO NOT BILL --
CURRENTLY AND RUPTURES --
WOULD ADD COST ON GOING.
THANK YOU IF I'M MAY I I I HAVE
A QUESTION JUST TO FOLLOW UP ON
THAT WHITE Y. Y. WITH THIS --
TAIL BILLY.
WELL IF AFTER TWENTY TWENTY TWO
THAT JUST ASSUMING WE WORK OUT
ALL THE PRE AMOUNTS OF MONEY
THAT NEEDED --
LET'S JUST SAY THAT THAT HAPPENS
--
AT TWENTY TWENTY TWO IT IT IS
THE RESPONSIBILITY OF THE
STUDENT HEALTH CENTER TO PAY FOR
THIS ON GOING I BELIEVE IT'S THE
AUTHORS POSITION THAT THE
STUDENT HEALTH CENTERS CAN BILL.
TO COVER THOSE COSTS WHAT WE'RE
SAYING IS WE DO NOT GO --
BECAUSE IT ADDS AYE IT ADDS TO
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS OVER ALL
FORMER STUDENT HOW THINGS IN SO
AND WE'RE NOT --
AT AT AT THIS POINT OURS ARE
STUDENT HEALTH CENTERS ARE NOT
--
FAMILY PACK PROVIDERS ARE MEDI
CAL PROVIDERS IN AND DON'T BILL
ANY.
FORM OF INSURANCE AT ALL.
THANK YOU IF CAN I CONTINUE YEAH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU AND TO OUR ARE SENATOR
THANK YOU --
FOR CHIMING A BIT EARLIER AYE
AYE [inaudible]
UNITS IT.
I'D OF THE IS A STRAIGHTFORWARD
DEL I I M..
I'D YOU HAVE A PROVISION THAT.
PROVIDES THAT AFTER TWENTY THAT
UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY TWO THERE'S
NO.
NOTHING IS CHAPTER LAOS AYE
REQUIRES THE PUBLIC UNIVERSITY
TO UTILIZE GENERAL FUND MONIES
ARE STUDENT FEES FOR PATIENT
PORSCHE.
BEFORE JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY TWO WHY THE PROVISION
BEFORE JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO BECAUSE WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY WERE
PRIVATELY FUNDED.
BUT WHAT HAPPENS AFTER TWENTY
TWENTY TWO I'VE LAID OUT THE
WAYS OF THE UNIVERSITIES CAN
CHARGE OR BILL FOR THIS.
ARE WE HAVE BEEN OPENED TO
HELPING THEM SET UP BILLING TO
MAKE SURE THAT STUDENT FEES WILL
HAVE TO BE USED FOR THIS --
MAYBE DIFFERENT OPINION ON THEIR
PART ON HOW WE CAN DO IT BUT
IT'S IT'S REALLY --
YOU CAN BECOME A MEDIC HELP
PROVIDE WE'VE WE'VE HAD THIS
CONVERSATION IN SENATE EDUCATION
ABOUT THE LACK OF UC'S NC ISSUES
ACCEPTING ANY KIND.
OF HEALTH CARE COVERAGE WHEN FOR
WHATEVER --
ILLNESS OR WHATNOT SO THIS ISN'T
JUST ABOUT MEDICAID ABORTION
OKAY THANK YOU AND I JUST WHEN
YOU SAY YOU'VE LAID OUT WHAT%
HAPPENS AFTER [inaudible] TWENTY
TWENTY TO WHAT I WAS ITS
REFERRING TO THEY LAID OUT
EARLIER WHEN I WAS ANSWERING
WHAT WE CAN DO ABOUT NINE THE
BILL IT IS NOT IN THE BILL IT'S
RIGHT HERE IN FRONT OF ME IS
THERE IS SO.
IS YOUR IN ANTICIPATION THAT.
GENERAL FUND MONIES ARE STUDENT
FEES AFTER TWENTY TWENTY TWO YOU
YOU HAVE THAT PROVISION SO THAT
THEY COULD POSSIBLY BE USED
NOTED.
THAT BAD THAT HAS NEVER BEEN THE
INTENTION OF THE BILL THAT
SHOULD BE OPEN TO AND I YOU KNOW
I DIDN'T TALK ABOUT THIS BEFORE
SITE NOT TRYING TO SPRING THIS
IS THE HIDDEN SPRING ON THE
AUTHOR THING BUT I'M NOT SURE
WHY THEIR NEEDS TO BE ANY
MENTION.
OF BEFORE JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY TWO IN THE BELL IF THE
INTENT IS TO ENSURE THAT.
GOING FORWARD IN PERPETUITY NO
GENERAL FUND MONIES ARE STUDENT
FEES WOULD BE USED FOR THE S.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS FOR A YEAR AND A
HALF AND WE ARE ALWAYS OPEN FOR
THE DISCUSSIONS --
I APPRECIATE THAT AND AND I AM
AND THAT WOULD THAT WOULD BE
SOMETHING THAT WOULD BE VERY
BENEFICIAL BECAUSE I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO HAVE A STATUS QUO
IN TERMS OF POLICY ABOUT WHAT
MONIES AND FEES COULD.
COULD GO --
TO THIS SERVICE.
ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE COST
CONCERNS THAT YOU SEE --
AND CSU HAVE HAVE BOTH RAISED TO
S. AND IMPLEMENTATION.
AND AGAIN --
TAKE A STEP BACK TO THE THE NEED
FOR THE BILL WE JUST HEARD
TESTIMONY AT LEAST FROM YOU SEE
THAT -- IN A
AND I THINK FROM THE OPPOSITION
THAT WITHIN.
MOST OF THIS CSU AND UC CAMPUSES
ARE.
IN AREAS THAT HAVE SOME
POPULATION AND THAT THERE MAY BE
A TENER FIFTEEN MINUTE BUS RIDE.
TO A FACILITY THAT COULD PROVIDE
THIS.
AND GIVEN THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES
WHY NOT LEAVE THIS UP TO YOU SEE
IN CS YOU TO LOOK AT THEIR OWN
CAMPUS NEEDS.
WHAT THEY DO HAVE THEIR OWN
COMMUNITY IT'S A LITTLE BIT OF A
LOCAL CONTROL ARGUMENT --
WE'D TELL YOU SEE AND WE TRY TO
TELL YOU SEE AND SEE IF YOU ALL
THE TIME TO DO BUT WE ALSO
SHOULD PRACTICE SOME RESTRAINT
IN THAT WHY NOT LET AN
INDIVIDUAL CAMPUS.
OR WOULD THE REGENTS OR THE
TRUSTEES FOR CS YOU MAKE THAT
DECISION --
AS I LOOK AT THIS I WOULD SAY A
COUPLE OF THINGS ONE I WOULD SAY
RECENTLY THE A LEGISLATOR JUST
LEGISLATURE JUST VOTED ON A BILL
MANDATING THAT SEE ISSUES AND
UC'S.
HOW PROVIDE MENTAL HEALTH SO WE
DO MANDATE ALL THE TIME IT'S
KIND OF WHAT WE DO IS A BODY BUT
NUMBER TWO I WOULD SAY MY
WITNESS WHO TESTIFIED --
FROM YOU SEE OUR AND TALKED
ABOUT THE DIFFICULTY SHE HAD
GIVING TO AN OFF CAMPUS
PROVIDER.
WHEN YOU ARE ON CAMPUS AND I DID
NOT DO COLLEGE THAT WAY I WAS
MARRIED AND WORKING FULL TIME SO
I DID NOT LIVE ON CAMPUS?
BUT EVEN THAT EVEN THAT MY OWN
EXPERIENCE YOU BECOME VERY
COMPARABLE WITH YOUR COLLEGE
CAMPUS YOU BECOME COMFORTABLE
BEING ABLE TO GO SOMEPLACE AND
ASK THEM FOR ADVICE.
HAVING MEDICAID ABORTION A
PROVIDED ON CAMPUS AT THE HEALTH
CENTERS GIVES THE STUDENT THE
ACCESS THAT THEY NEED.
YOU CAN ONLY HAVE A MEDICAID
ABORTION UP TO TEN WEEKS MOST
WOMEN DON'T EVEN FIND OUT
THEY'RE PREGNANT INTO THE FIVE
OR SIX WEEKS ALONG.
SO TIMELINESS AS OF THE ISSUE
AND YOURE ALREADY IN A
STRESSFUL SITUATION AND HAVING
TO THINK ABOUT WHERE DO I GO
WHAT DO I DO TO I HAVE A CARD
WHY NOT HAVE A CAR.
EVEN IT'S ONLY FIVE OR TEN MILES
AWAY.
IT'S STILL LOGISTICALLY
DIFFICULT WHEN YOU ARE ALREADY
STRUGGLING WITH WHAT YOU'RE
GOING TO DO TO BE ABLE TO WALK
ACROSS CAMPUS.
AND GET SOME ANSWERS IS IT'S
ABOUT ACCESS IT'S A
CONSTITUTIONALLY PROTECTED RIGHT
BUT IF YOU DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO
THAT CONSTITUTIONALLY PROTECTED
RIGHT.
IS IT REALLY RIGHT.
CAN I AM THE RIGHT NOW CAN A
STUDENT GO TO A HEALTH CENTER
AND ASK ALL THOSE QUESTIONS IT'S
JUST THE MEDICATION THAT THEY
CAN OBTAIN THAT IS CORRECT OKAY
--
I I WOULD.
REALLY BE VERY GRATEFUL AND HOPE
THAT THE PROVISION ABOUT JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO COULD BE
REMOVED --
AND THAT WE LOOK AT THESE COST
ISSUES WE'VE BEEN QUITE THE
WATCHDOG HAVE PARTICULAR YOU SEE
BUT ALSO CSU. FOR ON THE ENTIRE
TIME I'VE BEEN HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE AND EVERY SINGLE
TIME WE IMPOSE UPON THEM.
AND AND WITHOUT MUCH FLEXIBILITY
WHAT THEY NEED TO DO AND WE
DON'T BACK IT UP WITH ALL THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED OR THOUGHT
SAM LOCAL FLEXIBILITY I THINK
WE'RE KIND OF TAKING SOME STEPS
BACKWARDS.
AND THIS IS COMING FROM MEMBER
WHO IS PRO CHOICE.
SO I IT IS TRYING TO DETERMINE
WHAT WE MIGHT BEST BE ABLE TO DO
THEIR THANK YOU FOR ANSWERING
THE QUESTIONS.
YOU'RE VERY WELCOME [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
MR BABSON.
I WANT DOT EXPLORE --
THE RISK THE NEED AND THE CSU
LIABILITY AND I WANT TO FIRST OF
ALL.
THIS IS ABOUT ME --
MEDICATED ABORTION THIS IS ABOUT
ARGUE.
FORTY SIX ARE YOU OR ARE YOU
NOT.
CONCERNED ABOUT THE RISK
[inaudible]
OF CS USE OR THE UC'S
THE HAVING THE POTENTIAL FOR
LIABILITY AND RISK WITH RESPECT
TO THE SIDE EFFECTS OF A
MEDICAID ABORTION.
AND THAT THAT IS YES YOU'RE
CONCERNED HEARD.
WIENER BUSINESS SEEMS TO BE
CONFUSING I THINK.
SIGNIFICANT SO I WOULD ASK.
ARE YOU CONCERNED ABOUT THE
HEMORRHAGING AND THE POTENTIAL
FOR PROBLEMS WITH THE USE OF A
MEDICATED ABORTION.
THE I THINK FOR THE C. ISSUES
PERSPECTIVE.
IF THE HEALTH CENTERS.
ARE PROVIDING A SERVICE TO
STUDENTS TOM.
IN THERE THE INTENT IS THAT
THERE IT'S FROM MONDAY TO
FRIDAY.
NINE TO FIVE AND FIVE OR EIGHTY
FIVE ABOUT BALLOTS --
CRITTERS SURE THAT THEY'RE
THEY'RE BEING TREATED
SUCCESSFULLY AND WHEN I WHEN WE
DON'T HAVE THE CAPACITY. TO
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS OF THE
STUDENT --
WE IDENTIFY PRETTY QUICKLY WE
MAKE SURE THAT THEY GO TO THE
RIGHT PLACE.
THERE THERE IS A CONCERN THERE
IS A RISK IT IS MINIMAL THAT YES
THERE IS COMPETITORS A RISK AND
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
STUDENTS.
ARE ADDRESSED AND APPROPRIATELY
--
DIRECTED TO WHERE THEY CAN BE TO
THE PARTICULAR OF APPROPRIATELY.
YOUR YOUR ASSESSMENT OF A
MINIMAL RISK --
IT SEEMS TO ME THAT.
PARTICULARLY MEDICAID ABORTION
AND ARGUE FOR EIGHTY SIX DOES
HAVE --
ELEVATED RISK WITH RESPECT TO A
A COMPARATIVE [inaudible]
METHODOLOGY OF GETTING AN
ABORTION OUT WHAT CAUSES YOU TO
DETERMINE THE RISK.
IS A MINIMAL.
A FREQUENT WAS GOING UP THE
RESEARCH THAT WAS PROVIDED TO US
--
BY THE UCS HALF --
AND DR GROSSMAN DID COME TO THE
HEALTH CENTER DIRECTORS AND DID
PRESENT THAT AS WELL --
SO AYE I'M NOT I'M NOT BY ANY
MEANS AN EXPERT ARE YOU FOUR
EIGHTY SIX THE RISK ASSOCIATED
ARE I'M RELYING ON THE DAY OF
THAT TALK REST BRIGHTEST GOING
ANSWER THAT AS WELL OF COURSE.
YEAH JUST AYE AGAIN AS AS DR
GROSSMAN PROVIDED TESTIMONY IN
THE PREVIOUS ON COMMITTEE
HEARING --
ONLY ABOUT 3% OF PEOPLE GET
MEDICATION ABORTION WILL NEED
ADDITIONAL TREATMENT AND LESS
THAN HALF OF 1% WOULD NEED.
SIT TREATMENT AT AT IT MAYBE AT
A HOSPITAL SO IT'S IT'S QUITE A
SMALL PERCENTAGE.
LIKE TO ADDRESS OR HAVE THE CSU
IS TALK TO TO ME ABOUT THE NEED
--
AND THAT AGAIN I KNOW WHAT KIND
OF PUT YOU ON THE SPOT WHERE
WITH RESPECT TO THIS
[inaudible]
BUT A I YOU KNOW THIS IS A THIS
IS A SIGNIFICANT MATTER HERE WHO
--
WITH AGAIN AT THAT CAN YOU
ASSESS THE NEED FOR THIS IT I
MEAN.
IF THE INFORMATION WE HAVE ABOUT
--
ABORTION TO CHEMICAL ABORTION
PROVIDERS ARE WITHIN FIVE MILES
OR SO --
THAT.
SOMETHING SOMETHING LIKE THAT
THE SHORTEST DISTANCE IS OF A
MILE AND A HALF THERE ARE SOME.
CAMPUSES THAT HAVE AT SOME
AVAILABILITY MAYBE TEN MILES.
I'M AWAY WHAT IS THE OVER RIDING
COMPELLING NEED. TO PUT THIS --
PRESCRIPTION AND MEDICAID
ABORTION ON THE CAMPUS ITSELF.
IF THERE IS CLOSE PROXIMITY FOR
SIMILAR SERVICE.
I DON'T KNOW THAT I HAVE.
THE BILL WOULD ANSWER IT --
I REALLY LEARNED THAT THE AUTHOR
TO MISTER CHAIRMAN I LEAVE --
THE BERKELEY STUDENTS THAT ARE
PART OF THE CENTERS ON A CLUB ON
THE THE CAMPUS A PARTICULAR
PETITION WENT TO UC BERKELEY
LEADERSHIP AND ASKED TO HAVE THE
SERVICE PROVIDED ON THEIR
CAMPUS.
AND THEY WERE DENIED THAT SO
THEY CAME TO ME AND ASKED IF WE
COULD DO SOMETHING TO MAKE SURE
THAT EVERY STUDENT.
HAS ACCESS TO MEDICATED I THINK
YOU SAID CHEMICAL THAT WE'RE NOT
WE DON'T KNOW OF OF OF WHAT A
CHEMICAL ABORTIONISTS BUT
MEDICATED ABORTION SO THAT'S
WHERE THE NEED FOR THIS CAME
FROM IT CAME RIGHT FROM THE
STUDENTS.
I AM I THINK YOU PROBABLY --
ADDRESSED BE --
THE LIABILITY ISSUE BUT YOU.
IF YOU DO UNDERSTAND THAT
[inaudible]
DISPENSING A PARDON MEDICAL
ABORTION WITH THE POTENTIAL EVEN
43%.
WITH A HEMORRHAGE IN A
CIRCUMSTANCE IN WHICH BY YOUR
OWN TESTIMONY THE DUBBED REMEDY
FOR THIS IS --
THE EMERGENCY ROOM --
ARE YOU [inaudible]
HOW?
COULD YOU SCOPE.
YOUR LIABILITY CONCERNS ON A
SCALE.
A LOT OF LIABILITY MODELA
LIABILITY --
I MEAN IT'S GOING TO KEEP YOU
AWAKE AT NIGHT WILL THERE BE
CONCERNS WITH RESPECT TO THAT
ACTIVITY OR NOT.
SO I THINK THAT THE THE
CHALLENGE THERE THAT TWO THINGS
A LIABILITY CERTAINLY THERE'S
HOPE THERE'S A RISK AND I THINK
THAT -- FOR
US THE RISK WOULD MEAN THAT
THOSE STUDENTS WOULD NEED TO BE
SEEN IN AN EMERGENCY ROOM --
IT'SNOT THE HEALTH CENTERS ARE
NOT EQUIPPED --
TO BUT MOST OF OUR HEALTH
CENTERS WE WORKED DIRECTLY WITH
PLANNED PARENTHOOD AND THAT'S
FRANKLY WHERE --
OUR RELATIONSHIPS ARE TO FOR THE
SERVICE SO --
WE'VE NOT HAD TO DEAL WITH IT --
THE CONCERN OF COURSE IS IS WE
HAVE NO IDEA HOW MUCH RISK THERE
WILL BE.
I'M IN TERMS OF MEETING DEMAND
--
THEY WERE NOT SURE THERE'S AN
UNMET NEED --
ON MOST OF OUR CAMPUSES WE'VE
CERTAINLY TRAPPED ON THE NUMBER
OF STUDENTS THAT COME INTO OUR
HEALTH CENTER.
AND THE ONES THAT WE HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO SUCCESSFULLY --
REFERRED TO PLANNED PARENTHOOD
FOR THIS FOR THE SERVICE AND WE
WE DON'T SEE THAT THERE'S A HUGE
NEED FOR THE S. --
ALTHOUGH WERE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
SERVICE BECAUSE WE SO A TAPE THE
SERVICE WITH OUR COMMUNITY
PROVIDERS.
MISTER CHAIR MASK A QUESTION YET
DO ANY OF YOUR STERN'S COURT
CURRENTLY HAVE TO SEEK OF
TREATMENT FROM A EMERGENCY ROOM
NOW [inaudible]
OF COURSE.
SO THIS WOULD BE NOT ENTIRELY
DIFFERENT FROM A STUDENT WHO HAS
TO GO TO AN EMERGENCY ROOM WHO
MAYBE WENT TO THE HEALTH CARE
CENTER. FOR SOMETHING ELSE.
I I THINK THAT'S ABSOLUTELY TRUE
FOR STUDENT FOR EXAMPLE BROKE
AWAY COR THERE'S SOMETHING THAT
HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH THERE THERE
THERE'S ALWAYS SOME.
LEVEL OF OF I THINK POTENTIAL
USE FOR EMERGENCY ROOM FOR EVEN
SOME OF THIS THAT THE SLIGHTEST
OR UNEXPECTED KINDS OF
INCIDENCES.
I DO THINK ON THE ISSUE OF
LIABILITY OUR OUR OUR OFFICE --
HAVE NOT SCALED --
THAT THE RISK I I LOOK AT
LIABILITY --
FROM MORE OF A PERSPECTIVE.
WHAT HAPPENS --
LEGALLY IF ONE OF THESE CASES
ONE OF THE ONE IN A MILLION GO
WRONG BUT WITH THE UNIVERSITY'S
LIABILITY EXPOSURE BE AND AND I
DON'T KNOW.
I HAVEN'T HEARD OF A ARE WE
HAVEN'T SCALE THAT BUT IT'S NOT
ZERO IT'S NOT NOTHING BUT IT
IT'S IT'S SOMETHING THAT --
WE HAVEN'T SH OUR SELF INSURED
SO IF SOMETHING GOES WRONG ON
ANY OF THE PROCEDURES PROVIDED
AT THE STUDENT HEALTH CENTERS WE
WOULD HAVE SOME RISK.
THERE IF THE PROCEDURE IS
PROVIDED SOMEWHERE ELSE IT'S
LESS RISK FOR A FEW MINUTES.
BUT I DON'T KNOW.
THAT THAT NUMBER I APPRECIATE
THAT -- BUT
THE OPPORTUNITY TO EXPLORE THIS
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
--
I REPRESENT --
FRESNO STATE UNIVERSITY --
HAVE VERY GOOD AND VERY CLOSE
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE
EXECUTIVES THERE AND WITH THE
STUDENTS INCLUDING --
PRESIDENTS OF THE STUDENT BODY
--
OTHERS I'M IN A LOT OF FRESNO
STATE.
AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT THAT
FRESNO STATE A HAS SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS.
AND THEY ARE IN ONLINE WITH THE
RISK THEY NEED AND THE LIABILITY
AND FRANKLY I THINK OUR OUR OWN
UNIVERSITY WOULD RATHER THIS NOT
BE PUT IN FRONT OF THEM
PRESENTLY --
AND YET THE I UNDERSTAND WHY
THEY AND YOU ARE.
A LITTLE RELUCTANT AND DIRECT
TESTIMONY BUT I DO THINK THAT
THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT RISKS AND
LIABILITY AND I DON'T THINK THAT
THE NEED HAS BEEN DEMONSTRATED
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER EQUIPMENT QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
SCENE --
NINE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
SENATOR LATER I WOULD THINK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU EVERYONE
FOR THIS UP ROBUST DISCUSSION I
APPRECIATE BOTH SIDES OF THE
EQUATION WEIGHING IN ON WHAT
THEY THINK.
I AM I DO KNOW THAT THE
OPPOSITION SAID THAT NOT ONE
PRESIDENT WANTS THIS ON THEIR
CAMPUS -- I
HAVE NOT HAD --
AN OPPORTUNITY AS SHE APPARENTLY
HAD TO SPEAK WITH EVERY
PRESIDENT I HAVE TALKED TO A
NUMBER OF PRESIDENTS AS I'VE
TALKED TO THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UC AND THE PRESIDENT OF THE C.
ISSUE.
NEITHER HAD NEITHER OF THEM OR
OTHERS THAT I'VE TALKED TO HAVE
EXPRESSED THAT THEY DO NOT WANT
THIS ON THEIR CAMPUS.
THOSE ARE ONLY THE ONES THAT
I'VE TALKED TO I'M NOT SURE WHO
THE OPPOSITION HAD TALKED.
TO THIS IS REALLY IS ABOUT
ACCESS SURE THAT A WOMAN CAN
CHOOSE WHEN SHE DECIDES TO
INCORPORATE A FAMILY INTO HER
LIFE.
AND UNTIL WOMEN HAVE THAT RIGHT
TO HAVE ACCESS TO THIS
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT AND CHOOSE
WHEN THEY INCORPORATE A FAMILY
WOMAN WILL ALWAYS BE PUSHED DOWN
WE WILL NOT BE EQUAL MEMBERS OF
SOCIETY.
SO THIS IS A BILL ABOUT MAKING
SURE THAT ALL WOMEN HAVE THE
RIGHT TO MOVE FORWARD IN THEIR
LIFE WHEN THEY SO CHOOSE TO AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY BOAT.
THANK YOU SENATOR --
I WANT TO THANK ALL THE
WITNESSES.
ALL THE I STUDENTS WHO HAVE
COME.
AND AND GIVEN THEIR TESTIMONY --
I REPRESENT RIVERSIDE WHERE THE
CAMPUS OF UC RIVERSIDE IS.
I RECOGNIZE THE SERIOUSNESS OF
THIS BILL.
AND I LIKE MISTER PATTERSON
REACHED OUT. TO MY CAMPUS AND
SPOKE DIRECTLY WITH THE
PHYSICIAN IN CHARGE OF OUR
CLINIC.
AND I KNOW THAT THERE IS STILL
WORK TO BE DONE.
ON THIS BILL --
AND KNOW THAT THERE WILL
CONTINUE AND ASK THE AUTHOR TO
CONTINUE TO BE IN CONVERSATION.
WITH BOTH CSU AND YOU SEE.
AND I'VE BEEN TRYING I'VE THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THE BILL
FORWARD -- I
WILL SUPPORT IT.
AND I WILL LOOK FORWARD TO THE
CONTINUING DISCUSSION BETWEEN
THE AUTHOR AND UC AND CSU THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR [inaudible]
SO -- NO.
THINK THERE'S BEEN MOVED SAKE I
MISTER LEVINE AND SECOND BY
MISTER LOW.
AND MADAM SECRETARY IF YOU WOULD
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEDINA
AYE.
MEDINA AYE BAKER [inaudible]
ARAMBULA [inaudible]
BLOOM [inaudible]
CHAVEZ.
CHAVEZ NO IRWIN.
KILEY LEVINE.
LEVINE AYE LOW.
LOW AYE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NO QUIRK SILVA
SANTIAGO WEBER. THREE TO THAT
BILL IS ON CALL THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU MEMBERS.
MOVING NOW TO ITEM NUMBER.
FIVE MISTER HILL [inaudible]
YOU CAN.
WELCOME SENATOR THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS S. B. FOURTEEN
ZERO SIX GIVES THE FIFTEEN
EXISTING COMMUNITY COLLEGES
WITHIN PILOT PROGRAMS. TWO
ADDITIONAL YEARS TO ENROLL NEW
STUDENTS AND ENSURE THAT THE LA
O. WILL HAVE A MORE ROBUST POOL.
OF PARTICIPANTS FROM WHICH TO
EVALUATE THE PROGRAM'S
EFFECTIVENESS AND DEVELOPER.
AND WHETHER AND HOW THE PROGRAM
SHOULD BE EXTENDED OR EXPANDED.
IF WE DON'T PASS THIS BILL THE
PILOT PROGRAM SCHOOLS WILL NOT
BE ABLE TO ENROLL STUDENTS AFTER
THIS YEAR. TWENTY TWO OTHER
STATES ALREADY ALLOW COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TO OFFER BACCALAUREATE
DEGREE PROGRAMS THIS BILL IS
ABOUT THE FUTURE WORKFORCE IN
OUR STATE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE MEMBERS THE BILL.
WITNESSES --
AND SUPPORT TWO MINUTES TO TWO
WITNESSES.
YES SOME I'M CONSTANCE CAROL
CHANCELLOR OF THE SAN DIEGO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
DISTRICT THEM THANK YOU FOR
LETTING US COME I BROUGHT WITH
ME -- A
HANDOUT WHICH IS FOR EACH OF YOU
--
ON THE COMMITTEE SO THAT YOU
CAN.
A REVIEW THE INFORMATION I'M
PRESENTING.
THE BILL SENATE BILL FOURTEEN NO
--
SIX IS SUPPORTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE BY THE
LEAGUE THE COMMUNICATION LEAGUE
FOR CALIFORNIA.
AND THERE ARE SIX QUICK POINTS
THAT I WOULD LIKE TO MAKE.
THE THE FIRST IS THAT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE BACCALAUREATE
PROGRAM --
IS APPROPRIATE TO THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE MISSION.
AND YOU'LL SEE IN MY PAPER THAT
A GROWING NUMBER OF WORK FORCE
FIELDS NOW REQUIRE THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE BACCALAUREATE.
OR A BACCALAUREATE DEGREE
INSTEAD OF THE ASSOCIATE DEGREE.
MISS SECOND POINT IS THAT
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE QUALIFIED
TO OFFER THESE TO GREASE IN MANY
CASES.
OF THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
ALREADY OFFER THESE PROGRAMS AT
THE ASSOCIATE.
DEGREE LEVEL THE FACULTY THE
EQUIPMENT FACILITIES ARE ALREADY
IN PLACE AND THE THE QUALITY IS
EXCELLENT.
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
BACCALAUREATE PROGRAMS MISSES
IMPORTANT DO NOT DUPLICATE.
ANY PROGRAMS OFFERED BY OR PLAN
TO BUY ANY OF THE PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES IN CALIFORNIA.
CDVA CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM AND THE UC SYSTEM DO NOT
OFFER OF THESE TYPES OF DEGREES
IN DENTAL HYGIENE RESPIRATORY
CARE AND THE LIKE.
THE FOURTH POINT IS THAT THESE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE BACCALAUREATE
PROGRAMS ARE DESIGNED TO SERVE.
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS.
NOT OTHER TYPES OF STUDENTS BUT
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS WHO
ARE EITHER ALREADY ENROLLED IN
ASSOCIATE DEGREE PROGRAMS AT
THEIR COMMUNITY COLLEGES OR HAVE
COME TO THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE IN
ORDER TO PURSUE A FIELD.
THAT THAT IS NOT OF AVAILABLE A
A TO THEM OTHERWISE.
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
BACCALAUREATE PROGRAMS MY FIFTH
POINT OUR COST EFFECTIVE THE
ENTIRE FOUR YEARS ONLY CAUSED
HIM THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED SIXTY
DOLLARS.
WHICH IS A VERY IMPORTANT
CONSIDERATION --
TO OF PEOPLE WHO ARE NOW IN OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES WHO ARE NOT
WEALTHY.
AND SIX AND LAST THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS.
ARE NOW GRADUATING STUDENTS FROM
THEIR PROGRAMS WHEN THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S REPORT
CAME OUT.
OF IT CAME OUT BEFORE THE FIRST
GROUP OF GRADUATES AND IF YOU
WILL TURN.
TO OF THE LAST PAGE OF MY HAND
YOU WILL SEE THAT NINE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
HAVE ALREADY HAD THEIR FIRST
GRADUATES --
THIS SO THIS SUMMER IN MAY AND
JUNE.
OF THE STUDENTS WILL NUMBER A
TOTAL OF A HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE
BECAUSE THESE ARE SMALL
VOCATIONAL FOCUS PROGRAMS.
ARE EMPLOYED IN JOBS.
A IN THE FIELDS FOR WHICH THEY
THEY TRAINED.
JEFF INTO IF YOU COULD WRAP UP
PLEASE AYE WELL OUT THERE ARE
SIX COMMUNITY COLLEGES THAT ARE
ARE STILL HAVE FULL IN ROMANS
BUT HAVE NOT GRADUATED STUDENTS
YET.
ANTELOPE VALLEY MAYOR COSTA
MODESTO SANTA ANA RIA WE'LL
HANDLE AND SOLANO TO THE BOTTOM
LINE IS THIS OF THIS BILL WILL
WILL PROVIDE MORE INFORMATION
ABOUT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
BACCALAUREATE PROGRAM WHILE
SERVING.
A LOCAL NEED FOR STUDENTS TO TO
OBTAIN JOBS [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
SUCH CHAIR MEDINA MEMBERS THANK
YOU LARRY BELIEVES HIM THE
PRESIDENT OF THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA WE
REPRESENT ALL SEVENTY TWO
DISTRICTS.
SO FIRST BOTH THE C. E. O. BOARD
AND THE TRUSTEE BOARD VOTED
UNANIMOUSLY IN SUPPORT OF OF
THIS BILL.
HOT SO ONE ONE KEY POINT THE
BILL REALLY ENHANCES AND
IMPROVES THE DATA SET FOR
ANALYSIS FOR ALL OF YOU AS
LAWMAKERS --
TO LOOK AT THE PILOT'S EFFICACY.
I WILL PROVIDE MORE STUDENTS
STATISTICALLY SIGNIFICANT DATA
SET BY INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
GRADUATES AND YOU COULD SEE
WHERE WHAT HAPPENS TO THE
GRADUATES.
ARE EXTENDING THE SUNSET ALSO
REMOVES WHAT WHAT IS REALLY A
CONTAMINATING VARIABLE A OF OF
THAT RESEARCH AND STUDY IT'S
HARD TO MEASURE STUDENT DEMAND
WHEN YOU HAVE SUCH A CONSTRAINED
--
TIME PERIOD IN WHICH STUDENTS
CAN ENROLL SO IT LAW IT WILL
REALLY HELP US POLICYMAKERS TO A
PROPER ANALYSIS --
AS AS CHANCELLOR CAROL SAID THE
HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE GRADUATES
FROM YOU KNOW BAKER BAKERSFIELD
TO THE SOUTH TO SHASTA TO THE
NORTH --
DEMONSTRATE THE CAPACITY OF THE
COLLEGES TO OFFER THESE TYPES OF
DEGREES.
THIS IS REALLY AN IMPORTANT
POINT -- IT
FILLS THE GAP THAT EXISTS FOR
QUALITY PUBLIC OPTIONS. FOR
PLAYSPAN LOW INCOME STUDENTS
ESPECIALLY AND IT REALLY RIP
WILL REDUCE THE THE POSSIBILITY
THAT WILL HAVE.
MORE CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE
VICTIMS TO THE CORINTHIANS AND
THE I. T. T. TAX THAT ALL OF YOU
DEALT WITH AND AND KNOW THAT
THAT'S SUCH A BIG PROBLEM --
ALSO THIS IS AN EQUITY ISSUE
UNDERSERVED STUDENTS.
OUR ARE OFTEN THOSE WHO WERE
UNABLE TO RELOCATE TO PURSUE A
BACCALAUREATE DEGREE.
DOES PLACE POUND STUDENTS COULD
BE SERVED BY THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WHICH AS YOU KNOW OUR
THROUGHOUT THE STATE I WANT TO
END ON A TALE OF TWO STUDENTS
[inaudible]
ALICIA STEVENS WITH ALMOST SIXTY
YEARS OLD WHEN SHE DECIDED TO
RETURN TO SCHOOL.
SHE'D BEEN WORKING SINCE HE WAS
SIXTEEN YEARS OLD.
A FRIEND OF HERS HAD BEEN AT A
CORINTHIAN COLLEGE SHE ENROLLED.
SHE COMPLETED HER PROGRAM IN
ACCOUNTING SHE AMASSED TWENTY
TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS IN DEBT.
SHE WENT FOR A JOB INTERVIEW
THEY TOLD HER THAT DEGREE IS
FROM AN UNACCREDITED INSTITUTION
IT IS WORTHLESS I'M SORRY
[inaudible]
IN CONTRAST.
OR HAN BOK SHOCK WHO'S AN
IMMIGRANT FROM TURKEY CAME HERE
WHEN HE WAS TEN YEARS OLD.
IS FAMILY STARTED A SMALL
BUSINESS HE WORKED PART TIME AT
THE BUSINESS FROM ELEVEN YEARS
OLD.
HE ATTENDED A FOR PROFIT
INSTITUTE FOR TWO SEMESTERS
AMASSED TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
STUDENT THAT.
DIDN'T LIKE THE PROGRAM.
HE GOT MARRIED AND HE WHAT HE
TOLD ME THIS MORNING WAS HIS MY
WIFE TOLD ME TO GO BACK TO
SCHOOL.
SO HE EARNED AN ASSOCIATE'S
DEGREE IN GRAPHIC DESIGN AT
SANTA MONICA COLLEGE AND THEN
THANKS TO ALL OF YOU IN THE
PILOT PROGRAM [inaudible]
KEY.
I ENTERED THE INTERACTION DESIGN
BACCALAUREATE DEGREE PROGRAM
GRADUATED THIS SPRING AND
ALREADY WITH TWO OF HIS FELLOW
GRADUATES.
THEY HAVE STARTED A SMALL TECH
STARTUP CALLED PLAYGROUND VISION
THEY HAVE ENOUGH CLIENTS ALREADY
--
HELPING HELPING THESE CLIENTS
THAT THEY'VE REACHED INTO THE
SECOND COHORT AT SANTA MONICA TO
GET SOME OF THOSE STUDENTS TO
HELP THEM OUT WITH THEIR
CLIENTS.
AND HE GRADUATED WITH ZERO DEBT.
ZERO THANK YOU I'M GOING TO GO
TO WITNESSES.
GOT IT IN OPPOSITION O. OR I'M
SORRY IT'S OTHER OTHER WITNESSES
YES GUY WOULD WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT YOUR NAME.
AND I YOUR POSITION I HAVE BLANK
YOU THANK YOU TEAR MEDINA
MEMBERS MARK MCDONALD MCCALLUM
GROUP ON BEHALF OF A NUMBER OF
LOCAL COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS.
PUT HELD THE ANSWER KERN LOS
RIOS PERALTA SAN FRANCISCO SOUTH
ORANGE COUNTY AND THE YUBA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT SOLID
SUPPORT THANK YOU.%
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ASHLEY WALKER WITH NASIM AND ON
BEHALF OF NORTH ORANGE COUNTY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT.
IN AFTERNOON JOHN HANNAH WITH A
BRANCH OF SANTIAGO COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT.
ALONG WITH MISTER WEBSTER HERE
FROM COUNSEL PUBLIC AFFAIRS IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON ROSSETTI AND TO
HEAR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
[inaudible]
YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON DAVE PAROLED
PRESIDENT AMERICO SUPPORT OF
TRUSTEES AND WORKED THIRTY YEARS
IN THE BIOTECH.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MIKE
FINA MEDINA MATH AND SCIENCE IS
AMERICA'S TO COLLEGE NOW AUTHOR
OF THE BY MANUFACTURING
BACCALAUREATE AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT THIS BILL.
AND YOUR MUSE FISHER WITH THE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT.
CONNIE RHONDA I AM ASSOCIATE
PROFESSOR AT SAN DIEGO MESA
COLLEGE AND HEALTH INFORMATION
MANAGEMENT DEPARTMENT ME
THINKING A SUPPORTER BILL IN OUR
STUDENTS TO GET HIGH PAYING JOBS
AND HEALTH INFORMATION THINKING.
I'M HANNAH CUNNINGHAM A GRADUATE
STUDENT FROM SAN DIEGO MESA
COLLEGE AND I WOULD LOVE IF YOU
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS OLIVIA SCAT I'M ONE
OF THE FORTUNATE --
TO GRADUATE WITH THE FIRST
COHORT FROM SENEGAL MESA COLLEGE
WITH THE BETTER IT DEGREE IN
HEALTH WE SOME MANAGEMENT AND
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL.
DALE SHIMAZAKI WITH LOS ANGELES
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT AND
THE SANTA MONICA ME CLUTCHES
EXPORT OF THE BILL.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
PLEASE COME FORWARD. TO KAREN
MEMBERS OBVIOUSLY SHAUN BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY.
ASSOCIATION OUT WE ARE
REGRETFULLY IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL AYE WE BELIEVE THAT
PRIOR TO EXTENDING THE SUNSET
DATE ON THE PROGRAM THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY.
TO COMPREHENSIVELY EVALUATE THE
POLICY AND FISCAL IMPACT.
OF THESE DECISION --
TO EXTEND THE PROGRAM ON BOTH
THE MISSIONS OF THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM AND THE CSU AS
OUTLINED IN THE MASTER PLAN.
LAST DECEMBER THE ILIO ISSUED AN
INTERIM EVALUATION OF THE
PROGRAM AND WHILE IT NOTED THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE MADE RAPID
PROGRESS IN TERMS OF
IMPLEMENTATION.
THERE IS LIMITED REVIEW OR
CONSULTATION WITH THE CITY OF A
CEO AND IN FACT SOME DEGREE
PROGRAMS OR APPROVED OVER THE
SEA ISSUES OBJECTIONS.
CONTRADICTING BOTH THE LETTER
AND SPIRIT OF THE INITIAL
IMPLEMENTING LEGISLATION.
I THE LA ALSO FOUND THAT A
MAJORITY OF THE FIELD SELECTED
FOR THE PILOT PROGRAM DID NOT
REQUIRE A BACHELOR'S DEGREE FOR
LICENSURE OR CERTIFICATION.
WE HAVE STRONG CONCERNS THAT --
LIMITED STATE RESOURCE USED AND
IN THAT MANNER.
OF FINALLY WE UNDERSTAND THAT --
IT THERE'S LITTLE STUDENT
OUTCOME DATA.
THAT WOULD BE MADE AVAILABLE BY
THE FINAL EVALUATION DATE TO
HELP DETERMINE THE EFFECTIVENESS
OF THE PROGRAM.
AND AS THE LA O. REPORT ALSO
NOTES EXTENDING THE SUNSET DATE
WOULD WORK TO FURTHERING GREEN
THE PROGRAM AND THE STATUS QUO
--
POTENTIALLY TERM MAKING
TERMINATING THE PILOT PROGRAM
MORE DIFFICULT EVEN IF THE
OUTCOME DATA SHOWS THAT THE
PILOT WAS INEFFECTIVE FOR THESE
REASONS WE ASK.
FOR YOUR NO VOTE ON THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MICHAEL
YOUNG WITH THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION WERE ALSO A
REGRETFULLY OPPOSED THIS MEASURE
I WANNA SEE MY COMMENTS OF THOSE
OF THE CFC --
AND ALSO ADD THAT --
THE SCOPE OF THIS BILL SEEMS TO
BE WHERE IT SHIFTS THE CORE
MISSION OF COMMUNITY COLLEGES --
WE BELIEVE THAT THEY HAVE A ROLE
IN A VERY SIGNIFICANT ROLE TO
PLAY IN TERMS OF CATERS WILL.
FOR HIGHER EDUCATION --
HOWEVER WE DON'T WANT TO SEE
EARTHY CONTINUE SHIFT OF
RESOURCES GOING TOWARDS
BACCALAUREATE PROP --
DEGREES AND IN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM WHEN WE FOR THOSE
RESOURCES WOULD BE MORE
APPROPRIATELY USED --
AT OUR UNIVERSITY SYSTEM SO FOR
THOSE REASONS REPOSE.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
PUEDA COME FORWARD TO THE MY
YOUR NAME.
GROUP YOU'RE WITH.
GOOD AFTERNOON STEPHANIE DOWDELL
WITH THE FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
WOULD LIKE TO LINE OUR COMMENTS
OF THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION.
WE UNDERSTAND THE ARGUMENTS IN
SUPPORT AND I'M GONNA STOP YOU
JUST YOUR OKAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
ANY ANY CLEANERS.
SEEING NONE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
COMMENT --
AS CHAIRMAN THANK YOU.
UP FIRST FALLOUT.
I REALLY WANT THANK YOU CENTER
HOPE FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
AND FOR YOUR YOUR PASSION ON
THIS I SHARE IT.
HOW IMMENSELY --
CHEN AND I WERE A GREAT THAT
RECIPIENTS OF UP FRESNO CITY
COLLEGE.
AND WHEN WE WERE VERY VERY YOUNG
AND VERY NEWLY WED IT WAS A
WONDERFUL WE APPRECIATE IT VERY
MUCH.
OUR KIDS --
HAVE EXPERIENCED IT AS WELL
WITHOUT CLASSES THAT THEY NEEDED
UP WITH.
CREDITS OF A GOOD REASON EASILY
QUICKLY --
TRANSFER.
OUR AYE OF GET TO REPRESENT
THEIR WONDERFUL PLACES LIKE
REALLY COMMITTEE COLLEGE IN
CLOVIS CA A COLLEGE IN FRESNO
CITY CUTS THANK YOU FOR THIS.
THESE BACCALAUREUS ARE GOING TO
BE SIGNIFICANT.
IN HELPING STUDENTS WITH A
CHOICE. TO DECIDE HOW THEY WANT
TO GET THEIR EDUCATION AND
SPECIFIC FIELDS THAT THEY LOVE.
AND WHEN THEY GET A A
BACCALAUREATE.
THEIR EMPLOYABILITY GOES UP.
AND THEIR PAYCHECKS.
I THINK WE ALL WANT THAT AND I'M
DELIGHTED TO BE ABLE TO VOTE YES
[inaudible]
JEFF JARVIS --
BAGS LOT OF YOU KNOW WHERE THIS
BILL THIS PROCESS WE'RE DOING
RIGHT NOW STARTED WITH.
S. B. EIGHT FIFTY WHICH WAS --
MARTY BLOCKS BILL I WAS A CO
AUTHOR ON IT [inaudible]
IN.
RIGHT TECHNOLOGY YEAR AGO WE HAD
AN UPDATE IN THE SUB.
TO COMMITTEE WERE LOOKING AT ON
RETURN ON INVESTMENT THERE'S A
CONCERNS ABOUT HOW MANY.
A PROGRAMS ACTUALLY ESTABLISHING
PEOPLE GRADUATE IN THE COST FOR
THEM.
AND I APPRECIATE THAT WE HAVE A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE GRADUATE
SCHOOL WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
TOTAL POPULATION OF OUR
COMMUNICABLE JISR SEE ISSUES.
AS PRETTY SMALL.
IN AMMAN OF STUDENTS TO COMPLETE
THIS.
I'M GONNA BE SUPPORTED A THREE
YEARS GOING FORWARD --
BECAUSE ITHINK IT'S A GOOD IDEA
I THINK IT MEETS A NEED --
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT --
JUST LIKE A LOT OF THINGS WE DO
IN EDUCATION WE DID LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING.
OUR GOING TO DASH BOARD TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO MAKE
EDUCATION RELEVANT.
I CASE DO TWELVE AND TIENEN
TECHIE MANY COLLEGES --
YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S IT'S IT'S
THIS WAS A BIG SEA CHANGE THAT
TAKES AN EFFORT.
I THINK THREE YEARS A TROLLEY
PROBABLY GO.
FOR I WILL BE HERE AROUND HERE
THREE YEARS IN THIS IS DONE BUT
I WOULD SUGGEST THAT THAT.
YOU YOU TAKE US FORWARD
CAUTIOUSLY TRIED TO IMPROVE
THOSE NUMBERS SIGNIFICANTLY.
IS I AM FEARFUL THAT --
AS THEY DON'T.
THEN THERE'S GOING TO BE --
PROBABLY HEARING THREE YEARS
FROM NOW THAT WILL NOT ALLOW US
TO GO FORWARD.
AND THAT WOULD BE A DISSERVICE
TO OUR RESIDENTS IN NOW AND I
THINK IT'S IN A THERE'S GREAT
POTENTIAL HERE BUT RIGHT NOW I
DON'T THINK WE'VE REACHED IT.
SO I JUST.
I'LL SUPPORTED BY JUST WANNA
GIVE YOU COSTS.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE --
SENATOR HILL IF YOU'D LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN AND I APPRECIATE THE
CONCERN AND IN SOME OF THAT THE
REASONS IF I MAY RESPOND TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TRAVIS THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATTERSON FOR
THE FOR THE COMMENTS AND I TO
HAVE BEEN.
THE BENEFICIARY OF A GREAT.
COMMUNITY COLLEGE EDUCATION --
THE CHALLENGES OF THE CURRENT
BILL AND WHY YOU PROBABLY OF
WEIRD NOTICING LOWER NUMBERS IS
BECAUSE OF THE SUNSET.
THE SUNSET HAS PRE IT CREATED
SOME OBSTACLES IN TERMS OF ONE
PARTNERING WITH INSTITUTIONS AND
BUSINESSES WHO FELT.
WHY WOULD WE INVEST IN THIS
PROGRAM IF IT'S AREA A
OCCUPATIONAL TYPE OF A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE AND THEN HAVE
IT TERMINATE AND NOT HAVE THE
RESOURCES AS WELL AS STUDENTS
WHO DIDN'T WANT?
TO BEGIN THE PROGRAM AND THEN
HAVE AND BEFORE THEY COULD
FINISH THE PROGRAM SO THIS GIVES
AN OPPORTUNITY AND I THINK WE'LL
HAVE A GREAT OPPORTUNITY THANK
YOU TO THE CHAIR.
FOR HIS HELP IN THAT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE THE
INFORMATION NECESSARY AT THE END
OF THE DAY TO MAKE A GOOD
EVALUATION OF THE PROGRAM AND
SEE WHETHER AT THAT POINT IN
TIME.
IS WELL WORTH GOING FORWARD OR
NOT SO THANK YOU I'M AND I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO THIS FRIDAY
GOING TO THE MEETINGS OF THE
FOOTHILL COLLEGE GRADUATES AT
THAT THEIR FESTIVITIES SO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
MEMBERS THANK YOU BUT AGAIN
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THE BILL.
FOR OUR COMMITTEE SUPPORTED --
LAST YEAR S. B..
SEVEN SIXTY NINE WHICH AND THIS
LEGISLATION TAKES AN EVEN MORE
RESTRAINED APPROACH.
SO I BELIEVE THAT THE ADDITIONAL
DATA THAT WILL BE COLLECTED --
EXTENDING THE SUNSET WILL HELP
US GET TO A MORE COMPLETE
PICTURE.
AND TO THE EFFECTIVENESS OF THE
PROGRAM SO.
IF ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
BUT AT A MOTION BY MISTER LOW
HIS ACTION BY [inaudible]
MISTER CHAVEZ.
MADAM SECRETARY THE WE CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEDINA AYE AYE MEDINA AYE BAKER
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I BLOOM CHAVEZ CHAVEZ I
IRWIN KILEY LEVINE.
LEVINE AYE LOW LOW AYE
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE QUIRK SILVA
SANTIAGO WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I SEVEN ZERO YOUR BILL IS
OUT WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS A COMMITTEE CHAIR
THANK YOU CALLING THANK YOU.
AND NEXT SIZE SENATOR GLAZER.
IF YOU'D LIKE --
TO BEGIN WITH ITEM TO CENTER%
WHICH AT WHICH BILL IS THAT
WOULD IS S. B. THREE FOUR SIX
THREE FOUR SIX GOT IT.
IT'S THAT WHEN YOU ARE.
READY WHEN YOU ARE ALRIGHT THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT THIS BILL
THAT CREATES INCENTIVES TO
ENCOURAGE PARTICIPATION IN THE
CALIFORNIA PROMISE PROGRAM.
AS YOU MAY KNOW THE CALIFORNIA
PROMISE PROGRAM WHICH WE
ESTABLISHED LAST YEAR GET
STUDENTS WHO WANT TO GRADUATE IN
FOUR YEARS.
THE TOOLS TO DO SO SO FAR NEARLY
EIGHT THOUSAND STUDENTS ARE
PARTICIPATING.
BUT THE FACT IS THE PROGRAM
WON'T BE A TRUE SUCCESS UNLESS
WE HAVE EVEN BROADER
PARTICIPATION.
SO THE BILL IN FRONT OF YOU
OFFERS INCENTIVES TO ATTRACT
MORE STUDENTS TO THE CALIFORNIA
PROMISE.
AND ULTIMATELY WILL INCREASE THE
FOUR YEAR GRADUATION RATE.
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY.
DESERVEDLY THIS BILL WOULD DO
THE FOLLOWING THINGS FIRST IT
WOULD IT ESTABLISHED THE STUDENT
SUCCESS IN ON TIME COMPLETION
FUND.
I IN THE STATE BUDGET. TWO WOULD
ALLOW MONEY TO BE APPROPRIATED
TO THIS FUND BY THE LEGISLATURE.
TO BE USED FOR SUMMER GRANT.
S. YOU'D BE SUMMER TERM GRANTS
FOR THAT SUMMER SCHOOL CLASS
THAT MAYBE YOU CAN'T AFFORD.
THAT CAN KEEP YOU ON TRACK.
I TO IT WOULD ALLOW FOR ON TRACK
PROGRESS GRANTS CASH AWARDS TO
STUDENTS WHO ARE IN NEED.
OR THREE A TUITION FREEZE TO
QUALIFYING CALIFORNIA PROMISE
STUDENTS AT SPECIFIED IN THE
BILL.
I'M STARTING ON JULY FIRST OF A
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN AT THIS
BUT THIS PROPOSAL WILL PROVIDE
BACK IN TUITION WAIVERS FOR ALL
REMAINING CLASSES.
THAT IS STUDENT NEEDS TO
GRADUATE WHEN THE CAMPUS IS
UNABLE TO PROVIDE THAT PATHWAY.
TO GRADUATING FOR TWO YEARS.
I WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR AND
AND YOUR STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
ME ON AMENDMENTS TO STRENGTHEN
THE BILL.
IN PARTICULAR THIS BILL LIMITS
THE INCENTIVES TO STUDENTS ARE
IN NEED AND THEREFORE CATEGORIES
FOR THOSE THAT ARE APPLIED TO
THAT DEFINITION --
LOW INCOME UNDERREPRESENTED
FIRST GENERATION COLLEGE
STUDENTS I OR TRANSFER STUDENTS.
I IMPORTANTLY INCENTIVES CREATED
BY THIS BILL REQUIRE A BUDGET
APPROPRIATION BY THE
LEGISLATURE.
UNIVERSITY
CHOOSE WHICH INCENTIVES TO BE
USED THAT INDIVIDUAL CAMPUS
PROGRAMS. TO REITERATE THIS BILL
SPECIFIES THAT MONEY IN THIS NEW
FIND MAY BE USED BY THIS
TRUSTEES'. TO CREATE INCENTIVES
NOTHING REQUIRES THEM TO DO
THIS.
I AND THAT THE AUTHORITY WILL
CONTINUE TO REST WITH THE BOARD
OF TRUSTEES.
I'M NOT PLEASED TODAY TO BE
JOINED BY MARY DOLAN WHO
REPRESENTS THE CALIFORNIA STATE
STUDENT ASSOCIATION.
AND THE FOR HER TESTIMONY TODAY.
GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE CHAIR
MEDINA AND MEMBERS I AM AS MARY
DOLAN I'M THE GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS ASSOCIATE FOR THE
CALCIUM STUDENT ASSOCIATION.
WHICH REPRESENTS THE NEARLY HALF
A MILLION CSU STUDENTS.
WE ARE THANKFUL TO SENATOR
GLAZER FOR THE WORK THAT HE'S
DONE ON US BEEF THREE FOR SEX
THE CALIFORNIA PROMISE PROGRAM.
THREE YEARS AGO WHEN SENATOR
GLAZER BROUGHT THE CALIFORNIA
PROMISED BUILT OUR PORTS YES IS
A OPPOSE THE BILL.
AT THE TIME WE FELT LIKE THE
TUITION FREEZE INCLUDED AS WELL
AS THE IDEA THAT ONLY PRIVILEGED
STUDENTS COULD ACCESS THE
PROGRAM DID NOT HAVE CERTAIN
EQUITY AT THE HEART OF THE
PROGRAM.
MAKING OPPORTUNITIES AVAILABLE
TO ONLY THOSE STUDENTS WITH THE
FINANCIAL ABILITY TO TAKE THEM
IS NOT AN EQUITABLE SOLUTION TO
US.
MANY STUDENTS HAVE TO WORK
MULTIPLE JOBS TO SUPPORT
THEMSELVES AND MANY TIMES THEIR
FAMILIES. FOR THEM THE IDEA OF
TAKING FIFTEEN UNITS IT'S NOT A
QUESTION OF WELL AND LAZINESS AS
THE STUDENTS ARE TYPICALLY
WORKING HARDER THAN ANYONE COULD
EVEN IMAGINE.
AND AS AN ORGANIZATION THAT
REPRESENTS YES YOU STUDENTS WITH
SUCH A HIGH LEVEL OF POWER
RECIPIENTS FIRST GENERATION
STUDENTS AND UNDERREPRESENTED
POPULATIONS.
EQUITY IS AN ABSOLUTE PRIORITY
FOR US.
IT'S AN ARE VERY MISSION AS AN
ORGANIZATION.
THAT IS WHY WE ARE SO
APPRECIATIVE OF THE WORK THAT
HAS BEEN DONE ON S. B. THREE
FORTY SIX BY SENATOR GLAZER AND
THE STAFF. TO COME UP WITH
INCENTIVES TO ENABLE ALL
STUDENTS A GOOD FAITH
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THESE PROGRAMS.
WITH THE ADDED INCENTIVES SUMMER
TERM GRANTS ON TRACK PROGRESS
GRANTS DOT THAT NOT TUITION
COSTS AND NO TUITION CHARGE FOR
STUDENTS WHO TAKE LONGER THAN
FOUR YEARS.
YOUR INSTITUTIONAL FAULT THE
BILL NOW ADDRESSES MANY OF OUR
CONCERNS REGARDING EQUITY.
GOING TO COLLEGE HAS A NUMBER OF
BENEFITS FOR OUR STUDENTS
PARTICULARLY IN THE CAL STATE
SYSTEM THESE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
UPWARD MUCH SOCIAL MOBILITY IS
CHIEF AMONG THEM.
THIS PERSPECTIVE IS SUPPORTED BY
RESEARCH THAT ARE SHOWN MEDI CAL
STATE CAMPUSES ARE THE NATIONAL
LEADERS ON ENABLING UPWARD
SOCIAL MOBILITY.
BUT THIS BENEFIT IS NEVER
REALIZED AND STUDENTS ARE
ACTUALLY WORSE OFF IF THEY
CANNOT GRADUATE.
AT THE STATE CREATES PROGRAMS
THAT HELP STUDENTS GRADUATE
QUICKER EVEN SMALLER SUBSETS OF
STUDENTS THAT HAS AN IMPACT ON
ALL STUDENTS.
SIMPLY PUT.
GRADUATING SINCE QUICKER OPENS
UP COURSE BASED ACROSS THE BOARD
AS WELL AS ENROLLMENT SPOTS.
S. B. THREE FOUR SIX SEEKS TO DO
JUST THIS NOW WITH THE
INCENTIVES INCLUDED NOT ONLY
WILL THE BENEFITS OF THE PROGRAM
BE SEEN BY ALL STUDENTS IN THE
SYSTEM.
BUT THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PERSONALLY PARTICIPATE IN THIS
PROGRAM IS OPEN TO ALL STUDENTS.
WE THANK THE SENATOR FOR THIS
WORK AND HEARD YOUR AYE VOTE
TODAY.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
SECOND [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
WE'LL COME.
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OBVIOUSLY SHAUN BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
IN OPPOSITION AYE CFA HAS
CONCERNS ABOUT THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES THAT COULD
DISPROPORTIONATELY.
AND DISADVANTAGED STUDENTS
ALREADY CLOSE TO GRADUATING IN
FOUR YEARS AT THE EXPENSE OF
OTHER STUDENTS AND THEIR NEEDS.
WHILE WE APPRECIATE THE GOALS TO
IMPROVE DEGREE COMPLETION TIME
WE REMAIN CONCERNED ABOUT
DIVERTING FISCAL RESOURCES FROM
THE CSU SYSTEM TO A SUBSET OF
THE STUDENT BODY.
WHILE WE CONTINUE TO WRESTLE
WITH SIGNIFICANT FUNDING
SHORTFALLS.
SO FOR THESE REASONS WE ASK FOR
A NO VOTE THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
ANY TWEENER.
ANY QUESTIONS SIR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE [inaudible]
SEEING NONE --
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE AT HER
LEG AND THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN FOR YOUR GOOD WORK ON
THIS.
OUR MANY CONVERSATIONS I WOULD
NOTE THAT STUDENTS ARE CLOSE TO
GRADUATING AUTOMATICALLY GET THE
HIGHEST PRIORITY ON EVERY CAMPUS
ITS BASED ON UNITS THAT THEY'VE
ACCUMULATED SO.
I DON'T SEE ANYBODY REALLY
GETTING A DISADVANTAGE OUT OF
THIS.
I I THINK THAT OUR HOPE WOULD BE
AND I KNOW THAT.
CHAIRMAN YOU WORK SO HARD ON
THIS THIS YEAR TOGETHER --
TO TO RAISE THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
THAT WE'RE GIVING TO OUR SYSTEMS
--
WITH A FOCUS ON STUDENT SUCCESS
IT MEANS THAT THESE INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS GET FUNDED MAYBE NEXT
YEAR.
EVEN MORE THAN THEY ARE THIS
YEAR AND WE CAN CONTINUE TO HELP
KIDS GET THROUGH FASTER.
A TO EVERYONE'S BENEFITS WITH
THAT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION APPRECIATE DRIVE
OUT.
THANK YOU CENTER GLAZER --
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR WORKING WITH
MYSELF IN THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU TO THE STUDENT
REPRESENTATIVE TO I THINK MAKING
THIS A BETTER BILL --
AND AND I COMMEND YOU FOR YOUR
PERSISTENCE --
AND AND THANK YOU FOR THE WORK.
THAT AYE I WILL POINT OUT THAT
--
THAT ON PAGES SEVEN EIGHT OF THE
ANALYSIS THERE ARE STILL SOME
ADDITIONAL.
COMMENTS THAT I HOPE YOU WILL
CONTINUE TO ADDRESS --
BUT IT THIS IS NOW A BILL THAT I
CAN SUPPORT.
AND WILL BE SUBORDINATE HERE
THIS.
AFTERNOON WE HAVE A MOTION BY.
MISTER CHAVEZ AND THE SECOND BY
MISTER LOW SO MADAM SECRETARY
BUTTE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEDINA AYE AYE MEDINA AYE BAKER
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I BLOOM CHVEZ.
CHVEZ I IRWIN KILEY LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON PATTERSON ON AYE
QUIRK SILVA SANTIAGO WEBER
[inaudible]
WEBER I SEVEN ZERO YOUR BILL IS
OUT WE WILL LEAVE IT UP --
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
AND NEXT A ITEM FOR S. B..
TWELVE TWENTY FIVE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN THAT --
SP TWELVE TWENTY FIVE WILL
AUTHORIZE FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
FOR CRITICAL UPGRADES TO
CLASSROOMS LIBRARIES.
AND LABS OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY AND THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL WAS APPROVED AT A TWO
COMMITTEES IN THE FULL SENATE
WITH BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
WHAT APPROVED BY THE LEGISLATURE
AND SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR THE
BOND MEASURE WOULD GO BEFORE
VOTERS IN AN UPCOMING BALLOT?
FOR TOO LONG WE'VE ALLOWED OUR
CLASSROOMS LIBRARIES RESEARCH
LABS ON OUR CAMPUSES TO PAULA
DISREPAIR.
SPINAL PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED
INVESTMENT IN OUR HIGHER
EDUCATION INFRASTRUCTURE.
THERE'VE BEEN NO HIGHER
EDUCATION SPECIFIC BONDS PASSED
IN CALIFORNIA SINCE. NINETEEN
NINETY TWO NINETEEN NINETY TWO
THERE WAS A FIVE AND TWO
THOUSAND SIX FOR BROADER
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT HAD MONEY IN
THERE FOR HIGHER EDUCATION
CONSTRUCTION.
WHICH IS SINCE BEEN DEPLETED.
ACCORDING TO THE TWO SYSTEMS AND
YOU'LL HEAR FROM THEM --
THEY HAVE A COMBINED CAPITAL
NEEDS OF SIXTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS.
THIRTEEN BILLION FOR SHORT TERM
LONG TERM PROJECTS THOSE
LIBRARIES.
CLASSROOMS AND OTHER IMPORTANT
VESTMENTS.
I BELIEVE IT VOTERS SHOULD BE
GIVEN THE CHANCE TO CONTINUE THE
PROFLIGACY OF SUPPORTING OUR
UNIVERSITIES AND COLLEGES.
AND WITH THAT I'D RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE I'M PLEASED TO
BE JOINED HERE.
BY OUT MARY MOYLE THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITIES AND JASON
MURPHY MURPHY.
OF THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
GOOD AFTERNOON --
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS JASON
MURPHY ON BEHALF THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA.
PROUD TO BE HERE TODAY IN
THRONGS POOR THIS BILL
APPRECIATE THE SENATOR BRINGING
THIS IMPORTANT BILL FORWARD.
THE UNIVERSITY IS NOTED YOUR
ANALYSIS DOES HAVE A PARKS WE
EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS IN UNMET
NEED IN THE AREAS OF EXCUSE ME
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE AND CAPITAL
CONSTRUCTION.
OUR ABILITY TO CONTINUE TO SERVE
STUDENTS IS PREDICATED LARGELY
OUR ABILITY TO CONTINUE.
TO PROVIDE SPACE ON CAMPUS SO
GET NORDSTROM [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MARY MORE OIL WITH THE CSU WOULD
LIKE -- TO
TO THINK SENATOR GLAZER FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FOR FORWARD
WE ALSO HAVE APPROXIMATELY EIGHT
EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS AND UNMET
NEED.
AND THIS IS REALLY ABOUT
BRINGING SAFE AND RELIABLE BUILT
BUILDINGS TO OUR TO OUR STUDENTS
SO THEY CAN PURSUE THEIR
EDUCATIONAL GOALS --
AND WE URGE DRIVE VOTE THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
JAKE BREMNER CO CHAIR OF THE
EAST BAY LEADERSHIP COUNCIL'S
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AND
EDUCATION TASK FORCE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
MEDDLING CAL STATE STUDENT
ASSOCIATIONS PARK.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
AND EIGHT WINNERS.
NOT SEEN ANY.
ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
DOCTOR RUMBLE OF I HAD THE
PLEASURE OF TOURING FRESNO STATE
WITH OUR PRESIDENT THE EIGHTH
PRESIDENT WE'VE HAD PRESIDENT
JOE CASTRO.
AND WAS AMAZED AT THE LACK OF
INVESTMENT IN INFRASTRUCTURE AND
THE STATE OF FACILITIES AT ONE
OF OUR PREMIER COLLEGES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND FUNDAMENTALLY BELIEVE MORE
MONEY NEEDS TO BE SPENT --
FRESNO STATE ITSELF WAS SEVERAL
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS BEHIND
IN NECESSARY INFRASTRUCTURE
IMPROVEMENTS TO ITS CENTRAL
PLANTAIN COOLING FACILITIES AND
BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL IS AN
APPROPRIATE VEHICLE AND MEASURE.
AND I'M QUITE HAPPY TO SUPPORT
IT IN IF THERE'S EVER AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ADD A CO AUTHOR
I'D LOVE TO BE PART OF THIS IS
WHAT.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
WEB DOT WEB YES I APPRECIATE
THIS AND AND CLEARLY THERE'S A
TREMENDOUS NEED YOU YOU SAVE US
ABOUT WHAT FIFTEEN MILLION
BILLION AND UNMET NEED OR
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE IS THAT
WHAT IT WOULDN'T.
DISASTROUS ACCIDENT SHE THE ONE
OF YOU ONE OF YOU SAID ALL YES
THAT'S CORRECT --
FOR THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
IT'S A FIVE YEAR OVER FIVE
REPEAT TIME THAT'S OUR OUR EIGHT
MILLION DOLLAR FIGURE.
YEAH AND YOUR NAME IS THE SAME
THE SAME RIGHT OKAY SO WHAT IS
FOR BILLION GOING.
TO OF ANTI ISSUE.
I MEAN HAVE YOU FIGURED OUT.
WHAT FOUR BILLION WOULD WOULD
MEAN I MEAN WELL IN TERMS OF?
OF IF IF WE'RE LOOKING AT A
SIXTY HOLE YEAH AND YOU WANT
FOUR SETS 25%.
SO SPEAKING FOR THIS CSU WE HAVE
A FIVE YEAR CAPITAL OUT OUT LEE
PLAN WHERE WE PRIORITIZE
DIFFERENT FACILITIES AND PROJECT
NEEDS.
SO WHAT WHAT WOULD HAPPEN WITH
WITH THE MONEY IS.
THE PROJECTS WILL COME UP BEFORE
OUR OUR BOARD --
AND THEN IT WOULD COME UP BEFORE
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SO.
WE WE WE DO HAVE A FIVE YEAR
PLAN THAT. TO DEAL WITH FOR FOOD
DEAL WITH TWO BILLION DOLLAR
RIGHT RIGHTS WE WILL TAKE THAT
MONEY ACCORDING TO THE URGENCY
OF THE NEED.
UNIVERSITY WOULD CALIFORNIA DO
SOMETHING VERY SIMILAR AGAIN THE
URGENCY OF NEED WOULD BE
FACTORED INTO THE PRIORITIZATION
THAT THE UNIVERSITY GAVE IT BUT
WE HAVE PROJECTS ITERATED CHO
AND WHILE WE HAVE --
PROJECTS TO OUTSTRIP THIS
FUNDING THIS IS CERTAINLY A STEP
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION IT'S BEEN
AGAIN SINCE TWO THOUSAND SIX
THAT WE'VE HAD.
A GENERAL OBLIGATION BOND TO
WORK WITH.
NOW THERE'S ANOTHER BOND --
WITH EGGMAN AND HOWEVER THOSE
TWO A LINE THAT I YOU KNOW I I
SOMETIMES I BECOME.
CONCERNED IF WE GO TO THE PUBLIC
TOO OFTEN THAT WE WILL GET WHAT
WE REALLY WANT INSIDE NOT SURE
WHETHER THERE'S BEEN AN EFFORT.
HAVEN'T TALKED RELATED TO
COORDINATE BETWEEN THE TWO
BECAUSE BOTH OF YOU ASKING FOR
SIGNIFICANT DOLLARS HAS I THINK
MUCH MORE BUT NONE THE LESS IS
THERE A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE
TWO BONDS OR ARE AS A BEEN
CONVERSATION ABOUT.
COLLABORATION OR SOMETHING SO
THAT WE DON'T THEN IN THAT WITH
NOTHING.
YEAH HE MUST BE LOOKING OVER MY
SHOULDER AND MY SCHEDULE I THINK
I HAVE A FOUR O'CLOCK WITH US
ONLY WOKE IT EGGMAN. TO OUT TO
TALK ABOUT HOW WE'RE GOING TO
WORK TOGETHER I THINK WE BOTH
COMMITTED TO THAT I THINK.
HER NUMBER THAT SHE HAS IN HER
IS ABOUT SIX BILLION RIGHT SO I
BUT A PART OF THE AT THE
NEGOTIATIONS IS WITH THAT
DOWNSTAIRS.
MY AND THE HORSE YOU THAT THAT
WE HAVE A NUMBER THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S COMFORTABLE LIFE
ADVANCING AND SO.
WITH THE PILOT FOR DISCUSSIONS
WITH HER AND ALSO WITH THAT WITH
THE GOVERNOR DOES HE WHAT HE
BECOMES.
OUR NEEDS ARE TREMENDOUS AND YOU
MAY REMEMBER BECAUSE YOU'VE BEEN
AROUND AWHILE.
THAT I USED TO BE THAT HIGHER
EDUCATION FACILITIES REFUNDED
FROM THE COFFEE FUND ABOUT THAT
YEAH OFFSHORE OIL YEAH RECEIPTS
THAT CERTAINLY HAS NOT BEEN THE
CASE AYE ANYMORE AND THE GENERAL
FUND MONEY --
HAS NOT BEEN THERE EITHER SO AND
I KNOW THIS TREMENDOUS NEED ON
OUR CAMPUSES.
FOR OF JUST GENERAL MAINTENANCE
NOT NOT EVEN TALK ABOUT NEW
FACILITIES WHICH IS GENERAL
MAINTENANCE OF THE FACILITIES
THAT WE HAVE --
WHICH ARE ENORMOUS AND REQUIRED
SO I I'M SUPPORTIVE I JUST WANT
ALWAYS BECOME CONCERNED WE DON'T
ASK FOR ENOUGH --
AND PEOPLE GIVE US SOME AND THEN
WE DIDN'T REALLY HAVE ENOUGH AND
THEY PROBABLY WOULD HAVE GIVEN
US WHAT WE ASK FOR WE'D ASK FOR
IT YOU KNOW IT'S ON THOSE KIND
OF THINGS.
AND I THINK I HAVE THAT
EXPERIENCE IN PUBLIC IN SCHOOL
DISTRICT THAT WOULD WIND UP FOR
BOND AND AND WE GOT IT BUT WE
WASN'T ENOUGH SO WE HAD TO GO
BACK INTO ANOTHER ONE IN THIS
TIME WE WOULD GET A BIG ONE AND
PEOPLE VOTED FOR IT.
BUT OFTEN TIME TO SEE WHAT I
JUST GAVE YOU SOMETHING.
BECOME CONCERNED IF IF WE DON'T
ASK FOR NO.
SENATE GLAZER I'M GONNA TAKE
THOSE IS YOUR CLOTHES --
WE HAD A MOTION BY DOCTOR
RUMBULA SECOND BY MISTER BLOW --
MADAM SECRETARY WOULD CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DO PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEDINA
AYE MEDINA AYE BAKER.
BAKER I ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM I CHAVEZ.
CHAVEZ I IRWIN [inaudible]
KILEY LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW.
LOW AYE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE QUIRK SILVA
SANTIAGO WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I ZERO THE BILL IS OUT WE
WILL KEEP IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS BEFORE BEFORE WE DO
CONSENT.
I JUST WANNA RECOGNIZE OUR
COLLEAGUE OF MR CHAVEZ WHO I
BELIEVE WILL BE HIS LAST
MEETING.
WITH US IN THE HIGHER EDUCATION
AND I WANNA THANK.
ESTHER CHAVEZ FOR HIS SERVICE ON
HIGHER EDUCATION FOR A MANY
YEARS. SIX YEARS ALL OF HIS SIX
YEARS HERE AND I WANT TO SAY
PERSONALLY.
HOW MUCH I'VE ENJOYED A HAVE
MEAN --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAVEZ ON OUR
COMMITTEE.
AND HOW MUCH I'VE ENJOYED
GETTING TO KNOW HIM PERSONALLY A
TRAVELING TO MEXICO TOGETHER.
AND AND I JUST IS THE CHAIR THE
COMMITTEE.
GONNA MESS.
COLONEL CHAVEZ AND WANT TO THANK
HIM FOR HIS SERVICE THESE PAST
SIX YEARS.
ON THIS COMMITTEE.
AND VICE CHAIR.
SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE TO
UNDERSTAND IT.
THE CASSETTE.
THERE WE GO.
WE HAD A MOTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR GONNA GET A SECOND.
GODDESS MOVED BY MISTER CHAVEZ
SECOND BY BAKER BY MIDDLE MAKER.
OUR I MADAM SECRETARY OF YOU'D
CALL THE ROLL.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE BAKER.
BAKER I ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I BLOOM.
BLOOM I CHAVEZ CHAVEZ I IRWIN
[inaudible]
KILEY.
KILEY AYE LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW.
LOW AYE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I ZERO WHO WILL LEAVE IT
OPEN [inaudible]
FOR MEMBERS.
WE WILL GO BACK.
WE HAVE ONE MEASURE ON CALL --
ON CALL S. B. [inaudible]
THREE TWO ZERO BAKER.
BAKER I ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I BLOOM.
BLOOM I IRWIN [inaudible]
KILEY [inaudible]
KILEY NO [inaudible]
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA NOT VOTING
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I SEVEN THREE THE BILL IS
OUT WE WILL LEAVE IT.
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
OKAY ADAMS --
ITEM. TO S. B. [inaudible]
THREE FOUR SIX BAKER.
BAKER I BLOOM.
BLOOM I IRWIN [inaudible]
KILEY.
KILEY AYE.
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SANTIAGO. ELEVEN
ZERO BILL IS OUT WE WILL KEEP IT
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
ITEM FOUR S. B.. TWELVE TWENTY
FIVE IRWIN [inaudible]
KILEY.
KILEY NOT VOTING [inaudible]
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SANTIAGO.
AND ZERO BELIEVES OUT WE WILL
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR AND MEMBERS.
ITEM FIVE S. B. FOURTEEN NO SIX
BAKER.
BAKER I BLOOM.
BLOOM I IRWIN [inaudible]
KILEY.
KILEY AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SANTIAGO
[inaudible] ELEVEN ZERO THE
BILL IS OUT WE WILL KEEP IT OPEN
FOR ABSENT [inaudible]
HAS BEEN [inaudible]
SURE [inaudible]
EXCEPT
.
ITEM ONE S. B. THREE TWO ZERO
IRWIN [inaudible]
IRWIN I PATENT SANTIAGO
[inaudible] THREE THOSE OUT
WILL LEAVE IT OPEN.
ITEM TWO S. B. THREE FOUR SIX
IRWIN.
IRWIN NOT VOTING [inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
THINGS NOT VOTING TO OUR AYE --
THE SP THREE FOUR SIX IRWIN NOT
VOTING [inaudible] ELEVEN ZERO
THAT OPEN FOR ABSENT.
ITEM FOUR S. B. TWELVE TWENTY
FIVE IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE SANTIAGO. ELEVEN ZERO
THAT WAS. TWELVE TWENTY FIVE
ELEVEN ZERO COULD.
ITEM FIVE S. B. FORTINOS SIX
IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE SANTIAGO [inaudible]
FORTINOS TWELVE ZERO KEEP IT
OPEN [inaudible]
A MEMBER AND THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE SANTIAGO.
GALLAGHER
[inaudible]
TWELVE ZERO RICHARD